this is Jocko podcast number 392 with
Carrie Helton and me Jocko willink good
evening Carrie good evening
the truth is
we died together once before
we died together once before so says the
character Thomas Shelby in the series
peaky blinders
he's
speaking of himself and his brothers
who had served as Brutus soldiers in
World War one he and his brothers Arthur
and John as well as three of their
friends
Danny whizbang Jeremiah and Freddie
Thorne
we're in the field
and they were caught off from the
British retreat
as the British left the battle
they couldn't get away
they had no bullets left
they were simply waiting for the
Prussian Cavalry to finish them off
and while they waited
they decided they should sing the old
hymn In The Bleak mid-winter
then they waited to die
but in the end they were spared
for whatever reason
fate or
Providence or chance or destiny the
enemy never came and so they lived
and Thomas Shelby says at the end of
this story that we all agreed
everything after that
was extra
bonus
and that attitude
that perspective permeates in the way
that the Shelby Brothers lived
and the way many veterans live after War
this is something that war can do to a
person if you've
accepted death then
the rest is all extra
it's all a bonus
and so how do you live what do you do
are you taking risks
Reckless risks are you taking advantage
of every second that you have are you
living to honor the ones who didn't make
it home
or are you guilt-ridden that you did
make it home
are you trying to remember or are you
trying to forget
are you trying to leave a mark
or just trying to leave
I've seen some of my friends do some of
those things
or all of those things I've done some of
that's War
my friend Peter attia
told me a story once and I've probably
morphed it in my mind over the years
but it was something like this
he was an ER doctor at the time of this
story and there was a teenage girl who
was brought in
by her mother
and this teenage girl had
broken up with her boyfriend or
experienced some other kind of
adolescent drama
and she tried to kill herself by taking
an overdose
of Tylenol
and sometime it passed and the young
girl realized that this wasn't that
smart and she didn't want to die and so
she apparently told her mother
and her mother had brought the girl to
the hospital
where the girl's mother politely told
Peter the ER doctor
what had happened
and I can hear the conversation in my
head you know the kind of casual home my
daughter she broke up with her boyfriend
and
you know she took a bunch of pills and
and I think she probably just expected
Peter to
pump her stomach or give her the
antidote or give her an IV or give her
an injection of something or perform
whatever simple routine medical
procedure that would resolve the issue
and then the girl and the mother could
carry on Happily with their lives Having
learned from this little innocent naive
Mistake by this young girl
when Peter asked some questions
and did some math in his head
and realized based on how long it had
been since she had interest ingested the
drug and how much she had actually taken
as he ran that math in his head he
feared it would be too late because with
Tylenol there's a certain point of
absorption in the blood
where too much has been absorbed
and the liver is poisoned and the liver
fails and the body breaks down
and you die
and there is no procedure
and so Peter
quickly ran the necessary tests
and his fears were confirmed
but it was too late
there was nothing he or anybody else
could do
she was going to die
I've thought about that story a lot
from the girl's perspective from the
mother's perspective from Peter's
perspective
and I think about that story
and how it relates to my own experiences
with death which because of the war
those experiences have been too often
and too close
and I wonder sometimes do we realize the
value of life when we have it
doesn't encounter with death bring fear
or does it bring comfort
and what do we do and how do we act when
we realize
it's all going to end
because
it is all going to end
for everybody
There Is No Escape no one gets out of
here alive days months minutes or years
we don't know how much time is left but
the clock is ticking
like Thomas Shelby and his brothers we
are all caught off from the retreat
we will run out of ammunition
and we will be waiting
for time
to come and finish us off
In The Bleak mid-winter
now strangely or
I don't know maybe not so Strangely I
thought about all of this as I was
reading
Peter's new book the book is called
outlive
a much more positive title than the
subject matter I just addressed but it's
a book that should be required reading
for everyone and really it is
it at least touches upon or borders upon
being a textbook
a textbook where
Peter does his best to teach us what
he's learned
about health and about happiness and
about disease and diets and drugs
and about life and about death
and Peter's been on this podcast before
I think it was
2016. episode number 56 and it is a
privilege to have my friend Peter back
here again to discuss
well to discuss all these things
so Peter thanks for coming thanks for
coming by thank you for having me back
In The Bleak Midwinter how close am I on
that story
um one small detail off one large detail
off and the large detail is a good one
to be off on so I wasn't the ER resident
I was the surgical resident so I
wouldn't have been the first person they
encountered
but the good news is she was one of the
lucky ones in that while her liver did
fail we managed to get a liver
transplant for her in time oh she lived
she lived oh that wrecks my whole story
it actually makes my story a happy
ending it does but it's but it's the
same point because I was the first
person that she saw when she woke up so
most people in that situation die
because the liver unlike other organs in
the body you don't have a way outside
the body to support it we call that
extra corporeal support So if you take a
drug that destroys your kidneys you
could be put on dialysis for a period of
time years in fact until you've got a
transplanted kidney
even the heart is true in that way if
you took something that was so toxic to
the heart you could be put on a
ventricular assist device or something
like that until a heart transplant came
along the liver we have no option for
that so you've got
got in the case of this girl if I recall
you probably have about a 20 a 36 hour
window to get her a liver and that's not
big odds so there's a decent chance that
you just die she was one of the really
lucky ones so she got a liver
and I you know I just remember taking
care of her when she's you know in the
ICU and
you know I think it's a very I mean
again she was very young right so she
was probably late teens early 20s
probably an unbelievable feeling of
Shame
um
and you know I'm sure you read these
accounts of the few people who have
survived jumping off the Golden Gate
Bridge yeah and they all say the same
thing right I mean there's only a
handful of them that have survived
and that two things they all say are
they can't believe how long it takes to
hit the water it's technically about a
three second fall but they describe it
as taking like minutes
and two they again it's an all it's a
small n but they all say
the second they jump they can't believe
how much it puts in perspective whatever
it was that made them jump
sketchy that's uh that's crazy I was
looking at statistics on the Coronado
Bay Bridge and I think
I I want to say like 10 people have
survived is that too big of a number how
many people did you say survived uh San
Francisco
it's on the order of of 10 or so and and
I'm trying to think like the Golden Gate
Bridge probably averages two a month
yeah
it's a similar number it's a similar
number it gets shut down all the time
because people are jumpers are up there
um all right so you wrote this book
we're going to get into it a little bit
and you've also done a bunch of podcasts
about the book the book you did the
audiobook of the book I'm gonna try not
to read too much of the book but you
know me I probably will read more than I
should
um
it starts off with this
going to the book the intro of the book
once again the book is called out live
the science and art of longevity and
it's a lot more than just that in the
dream I'm trying to catch falling eggs
I'm standing on a sidewalk in a big
dirty City that looks like a lot like
Baltimore holding a padded basket and
looking up every few seconds I spot an
egg whizzing down from me from above
and I run to try and catch it in the
basket they're coming at me fast and I'm
doing my best to catch them running all
over the place with my basket
outstretched like an outfielder's glove
but I can't catch them all some of them
many of them smack the ground
splattering yellow yolk all over my
shoes and medical scrubs I'm desperate
for this to stop
where the X coming from there must be a
guy up there on the top of the building
or on a balcony just casually tossing
them over the rail but I can't see him
and I'm bit so busy I barely even have
time to think about him I'm just running
around trying to catch as many eggs as
possible and I'm failing miserably
emotion Wells up in my body as I realize
that no matter how hard I try I'll never
be able to catch all the eggs
I feel overwhelmed
and helpless
that's the opening of the book this is a
very similar like military dudes like me
we have a dream where the enemy's coming
and we're running out of ammo it's kind
of like the Tommy Shelby thing like
we're running out of ammo and then you
run out and you're looking for other
magazines and the enemy's closing on you
and you know what's gonna happen and you
that's when you wake up drenched in
sweat
and you're all happy you don't really
call him and just in bed we're all good
but this was the this is how you viewed
what medicine was doing what you call in
the book medicine 2.0 which is here's a
problem right here let's fix it right
now and not try and figure out where
it's coming from
that's the impact that this dream had on
you is to to to make you think of
medicine in a different way
yeah although not at the time right it's
only in retrospect that I put two and
two together at the time
um yeah it just seemed like it's amazing
to me that it wasn't obvious what that
dream was about at the time because it's
so obvious in retrospect oh so you what
you thought it was about at the time was
you needed to get better with the basket
and be able to move quicker and be able
to catch more just some stress just
stress like it was just some dream about
internalizing stress
how often do you remember your dreams
now
oh you know it's funny if I'm really
deliberate about thinking about it first
thing in the morning I would say
probably more than half the time
are your dreams good or your dreams bad
very rarely do I wake up and think that
they're significant
um about
oh I don't know
maybe a little less than half the time
that I do remember a dream I can at
least say I bet that's me ruminating on
this fear or this concern
um but there I would say that the
valence of my dreams tends to be
negative it's rare that I wake up and
think oh I wish I was still sleeping
having that dream it's usually I'm glad
that's over that could be some kind of a
bias though because if you're having a
bad bad dream seem to wake you up more
then good dreams I bet we just like
happy good dreams you keep sleeping I
can always tell when I've had like a a
bad dream because I wake up just
drenched in sweat and it's nasty and my
wife is like you are as disgusting and
I'm like yeah I'm sorry but it's always
like you're running for ammo you're
doing something you're trying to catch
someone like something's going on like
that it's weird that you physically
sweat even when you're not
moving
yeah for sure I mean it's still there's
still huge sympathetic uh you know uh
nervous system is is activated I mean
it's uh it wouldn't know the difference
right yeah I guess well mine doesn't
that's for damn sure all right I'm gonna
fast forward a little bit and go read
another chunk of the book I'll never
forget the first patient whom I ever saw
die
it was early in my second year of
medical school and I was spending a
Saturday evening volunteering at the
hospital which is something the local
school or the school encouraged us to do
but we were only supposed to observe
because by that point we knew just
enough to be dangerous
at some point a woman in her mid-30s
came into the ER complaining of
shortness of breath
she was from East Palo Alto a pocket of
poverty
in that very wealthy Town while the
nurses snapped a set of EKG leads on her
and fitted an oxygen mask over her mouth
and nose I sat by her side trying to
distract her with small talk what's your
name do you have kids how long have you
been feeling this way
all of a sudden her fight her face
tightened with fear
and she began gasping for breath then
her eyes rolled back and she lost
consciousness
within seconds the nurses and doctors
flooded into the ER Bay and began
running a code on her snaking a
breathing tube down her Airway and
injecting her full of potent drugs and a
last-ditch effort at resuscitation
meanwhile one of the residents began
doing chest compressions on her prone
body every couple of minutes everyone
would step back as the attending
physician slapped the defibrillation
paddles on her chest and her body would
twitch with immense jolt of electricity
everything was precisely choreographed
they knew the drill
I shrank into a corner trying to stay
out of the way but the resident doing
CPR caught my eye and said hey man can
you come over here and relieve me just
pump with the same force and Rhythm I as
I am now okay so I began doing
compressions for the first time in my
life on someone who is not a mannequin
but nothing worked
she died right there on the table as I
was still pounding on her chest
just a few minutes earlier I've been
asking about her family
a nurse pulled the sheet up over her
face and everyone scattered as quickly
as they had arrived
this was not a rare occurrence for
anyone else in the room
but I was freaked out horrified
what the hell had just happened
do they give you any heads up at all are
they talking to you about this any of
this from a psychological perspective
when you are going through
doctor School
certainly not when I was there I I don't
know what it's like today but
[Music]
you know it would only go from bad to
worse right I mean I went to medical
school at Stanford where that's often
how you saw somebody die but it you know
in residency I was at Hopkins which was
more of a war zone so there
what I saw his death was penetrating
trauma for the most part in car
accidents as well but but I would say
the majority of the people that died
well
um you know right in my hands would have
been trauma victims
um and you certainly saw people die post
surgical procedures you know somebody
dies after cancer surgery or heart
surgery
um but they usually didn't die right
while you were watching them the the
ones who die when you're standing there
pumping on their chest and trying to do
something heroic or usually trauma
victims and that was just very that was
a very common occurrence and no I don't
think that was ever
um
yeah there was just there was no there
was no sense of how do you process this
um and I I don't know that I did a great
job of it I mean I probably internalized
it more than was healthy
um
I I I feel like um yeah there were many
times when I
after right after that person would die
I would do something like I picked their
I take their wallet and look through it
and like find a picture of them or
something like that and it's it you know
I mean I'm sure your audience can handle
it but like I remember the first time I
saw somebody literally whose brains had
been blown out we use those terms very
Loosely right but but you know what
that's like I mean when you see a person
with an entry wound yay big and an exit
wound on the other side of their head
yay big and their brains are on the
gurney
that's not what they looked like 10
minutes earlier an hour earlier that's
not what they look like in their
driver's license photo
and um
yeah I just think I think that is
something that we would be better
prepared to or we would have been better
off if we'd had some sense of how do you
compartmentalize that
yeah I can tell you that I don't think
the military does a good job of that
kind of stuff at least it didn't when I
was in we didn't talk about it it's in
fact it's interesting we even talk about
like hate
if someone dies what do we do what's our
replacement plan for that individual
like where are we are we gonna get
another guy I was like oh no that won't
happen well it was so far from our heads
of thinking it could happen that we
didn't even have some kind of a
replacement plan you know you talk about
World War II they had replacement plans
and Vietnam had replacement plans oh
here's what you're going to get for
Replacements we have another platoon
full of stragglers that they're going to
come in on the you know the fourth wave
and they'll fill in whoever's whatever
spots are empty we didn't have that so
that means you're not even thinking
about it so now you're not thinking
about it it's like okay what what goes
on what goes on what how do people how
are people supposed to handle it so it's
interesting that even in medical school
where you are 100 going to see people
die
you're not giving any sort of prep for
that now listen it's also like oh you're
going to be inundated with that and
we've been doing it for however many
years 100 200 300 years there's been
people going to medical school and
people figured out so we're good
yeah I mean I think that I think the
disadvantage of that approach in medical
school is that it produces a level of
callousness that I think all of us
experience to some extent which is you
tend to retreat from from Death now when
it's acute death you don't have a choice
you don't have time to retreat I mean
when that patient comes in who's been in
a horrible car accident or he's been
shot or stabbed you're going to be there
and do your job and they're going to die
and that's that but you do tend to
retreat from their family and and you
know you have an enormous obligation I
think to the family of someone who dies
under your watch
um and in trauma it is especially
difficult to wrap your head around this
because by definition the last time that
family member saw them they were a
hundred percent normal
like their kid left the house today
totally fine
and got T-boned in a car accident and
now they're dead
who who should be the one to talk to
them
I I think that the physician has to be
there now it's it's true that hospitals
have social workers and have people that
can come in to help with that
but but I think that the doctor needs to
be there
um and and we don't we didn't certainly
get any training uh in that and I think
a lot of doctors don't want to be there
for that because they don't feel
equipped
I was on my first deployment to Iraq and
I'm not going to go into the details of
what happened but essentially we had
ended up recovering a body
of an American Soldier
and we put this this individual you know
he's in a body bag he's in the back of
our vehicle
in in the back of a Humvee and one of my
friends was
in in the back seat I'm in the front
seat and um
it was yeah it was
we're driving and the the the body the
bag started to leak and my friend who is
in the back seat like he's all of a
sudden there's the blood is kind of
going on to his boots it's running down
a seat or whatever
and
he's yelling at me you know he's yelling
at me and yelling you know
can pull over we [__] you know he's
he's he's he's I he's mad he's irate and
we can't like pull over he can't just
like stop him on the middle of a convoy
or we could but like well now what
additional risk are we incurring and
he's yelling and this guy's a dear
friend of mine but it it was one of
those things where I'm thinking
this is going to leave a deep mark on
and this was we this was a soldier that
we didn't know this was a soldier that
we went out and and helped recover and
so we didn't know this this soldier at
all and yet my friend is in the back
seat he's got his this guy's blood is
leaking into the the way a Humvee set up
it's sort of like you're in a in a
I guess a way to describe it would be
you know the lunch school lunch trays
that you have that have like a little
village yeah so you have like the
division for your seats and there's a
place where your feet go and it's all
one big molded thing and so that is what
kind of tracked blood into my friend's
feet
and I could hear in his voice he was
just
um you know yelling at me like [__]
stop hey boy can't be smokeless and he
I'm like hey bro we're gonna be okay we
can't stop right here come on man we
can't stop
and uh yeah again that was he probably
hadn't thought about
that at this juncture in his career in
the military and be and you know what I
did when we got back nothing I didn't
pull him aside I didn't say hey bro or
UK I didn't do any of that we just like
hey what's our next mission you know so
it's another case where sure
and you know what he did got ready for
the next mission you know what I mean
that's what he did but it it it
functions but as you mentioned it's it's
definitely not the optimum way to go
about dealing with this kind of thing
in life
um
listen this book is big
and 410 pages of actual book and then I
think it's got a little more after that
um
obviously I'm not gonna read the whole
thing and you you read that I've
listened to the sample the audiobook you
read it you did an outstanding job and I
think you realized how hard it is to
read books that's the hardest thing I've
ever done it's a challenge for sure but
get the book get the audiobook listen
you've done a bunch of podcasts you
you've been on rogans you've been on um
huberman's you've been on Peterson's
like you've been you've done a bunch of
podcasts around the book and they're and
there's a lot there's oh you guys Deep
dive into a bunch of different stuff
um
so I'm feeling like I'm getting a little
I'm going to be getting a little bit
tangential in this with what I'm going
to be talking about or what I want to
what may what the book makes me think
about that's outside of the normal stuff
you say in this second book I think
about health span and its deterioration
in terms of three categories or vectors
the first Vector of deterioration is
cognitive decline our processing speed
slows down we can't solve complex
problems with the quickness and ease
that we once did our memory begins to
fade our executive function is less
reliable our personality changes and if
it goes on for long enough even our
setting itself is lost fortunately most
people don't progress all the way to
Frank dementia but many people
experience some decline in their
cognitive capacity as they age our
objective is to minimize this the second
Vector of deterioration is the decline
and eventual loss of the function of our
physical body this may precede or follow
cognitive decline there is no
predetermined order but as we grow older
Frailty stalks us we lose muscle mass
and strength along with density stamina
stability and balance until it becomes
almost impossible to carry a bag of
groceries into the house chronic pain
prevents us from doing things that we
once did with ease at the same time
inexorable progression of disease might
leave us gasping for breath when we walk
to the end of the driveway to fetch the
newspaper
or we could be living a relatively
active and healthy life until we fall or
suffer some unexpected injury
that tips us into a downward spiral from
which we may never recover
my patients rarely expect this decline
to affect them
and when I read that we had a guy on the
podcast a guy named Dean Ladd who's in
the United States Marine Corps in World
War II
and he had done I forget which island
can he did multiple Island assaults with
the Marine Corps in the Pacific and he
was on I think it might have been his
second
but he had already done one or two
Island assaults in the Pacific
and so he's going into Tarawa
and as he's going into Tarawa I was
asking him I said hey we're you know
were you
scared and he was like no because in his
mind he's this is what he said on the
podcast he's like in my he said I none
of this stuff could happen to me like it
was going to happen to the other guys
I'm sure the other guys must have been
scared because because maybe they
thought they were going to get shot
maybe they thought they thought they
were going to get blown up but I wasn't
scared because that wasn't going to
happen to me and he ended up actually
getting gut shot 800 meters off the
beach and only by the
disobeying orders of two other marines
that dragged him back to a boat and
threw him on did he live
but what do you think that is what do
you think it is in human beings myself
included a hundred percent I by the way
believe that if I'm on a commercial
aircraft and it blows up in the sky I'm
gonna survive so what what is that and
and how does that how do you have to try
and convince people
that they are actually part of this
well the first question is the hard one
uh and also the one for which I I just
don't think I have an answer
um I mean there's probably some
evolutionary reasons for it
um I think there are I think it stems
from a broader problem so I don't know
if you've read Oliver berkman's book 4
000 weeks no uh it's it's a fantastic
book uh and I I've had him on the
podcast as well although by the time
this one comes out it might not yet be
out because I just interviewed him
recently
um
but he talks about sort of one of the
most important
issues with respect to the human
condition is our inability to to cope
with finitude like we simply can't
accept the finite nature of our lives
and that's why he really uses this 4 000
weeks thing it's a very jarring thing
um I I keep a calendar in my office on
the wall with one block for each week so
it's got 52 blocks per row and it's got
88 rows you know assuming I'm going to
live to 88 which of course there's zero
guarantee I will
and every Sunday I color in a block
so you know I'm into like the 51st row
of coloring in those blocks those rows
are looking lean boy well there's no
denying I'm more than halfway done and
my kids every day they come and they
look at this thing and even they're
starting to figure out like Daddy's more
than halfway through life and
um so I think there's something
important about putting that in front of
our face now I have an advantage
that I think the average person doesn't
which is I've spent a lot more time
observing the end of life
um this this thing I call the marginal
decade so the marginal decade is just
defined as the last decade of your life
which by definition Nobody Knows the day
they enter it like nobody knows that any
including people who die of natural
causes they don't know the actual day
they are standing 10 years away from the
end of their life
but most people know when they're in it
you know most people have a sense of
I've got less than 10 years to go as as
someone I once spoke with about
described it to me he goes I'm on my
last roll of toilet paper
and I'm going to be very careful about
how I use each Square
no more gratuitous toilet paper using
around here every minute counts and of
course if we could apply that principle
at the beginning you know that that's a
different situation
so so I suspect that that this is such a
painful concept for us that we just
simply irrationally block it out and say
that's not going to be me like you know
and also it's so it it you know it
occurs over a relatively long period of
time that you think well
all right look I'm in my 50s today and I
mean I'm I can do anything there's
nothing I can do it's not like I'm going
to wake up one day and not be able to do
all of these things so when we ask our
patients
um to go through this exercise which is
a part of the marginal decade exercise
which is
Define we Define your centenarian
decathlon so we give them a list of like
50 activities some of these are
activities of daily living like do you
want to be able to
carry a piece of luggage up an escalator
that's broken
so 30 pound luggage carried up two
flights of stairs functionally
some of these are you know very
recreational specific like do you want
to be able to go and Hike you know this
many miles at this speed over this type
of terrain
um and we show people this list of 50
and we're like pick the 10 that matter
most to you
the ambition that people come up with is
remarkable
oh I'm going to be heli skiing in my
marginal decade and they're very serious
about this they're very serious about
this because they can heli ski in their
40s which is what I'm asking them to do
this and in their mind there's no reason
they shouldn't be heli skiing 50 years
from now
um
and I don't want to tell them they're
not I just want to show them
that the amount of strength eccentric
strength concentric strength
cardiorespiratory Fitness like I do we
March through the measurable metrics the
amount of things you need to do that are
here
if you want to do this when you're 85
and we know the rates at which these
things decline
this is where you need to be at 45 in
terms of those metrics and you're only
here you're well below that so you're
still above the threshold to do them but
nowhere near above the threshold
given the inevitability decline in other
words you're telling me that you want
your glider to be able to fly another
two miles
but you're only 500 yards in the air if
you want to go another two miles you
need to be a mile up
the deterioration is inevitable
the decline is inevitable
decline is inevitable we have some
control over the pace of it we do so so
in other words
the first derivative is absolutely
negative once you reach a certain age
but you have a lot of say in the
magnitude of that derivative
so you got this this chapter in here is
called uh the centarians and you look at
a bunch of people that are over a
century old which is pretty awesome
which is pretty awesome to be oh how old
are you I'm a century old that's pretty
awesome and you got a bunch of different
examples in there and of course you cite
a bunch of examples where the people are
drinking whiskey and smoking cigars and
you go through all of that
when I was reading this
you know I've written some books and the
the fiction books I've written which are
one adult fiction book when and a bunch
of kids fiction books
story needs an arc right you kind of
have a story arc
and
sometimes I look at a lifespan of 80
years or whatever you said 88 years 70
years like
pretty good story arc you can fit a good
solid story arc in there
how long is long enough
in terms of lifespan yeah
well I mean look there's a lot of
cliches and ways to look at this right
it's not about the the length of life
it's about the quality of life it's it's
it's not the number of years it's the
Life In Those Years
um
look I think there are extreme examples
that we would all agree are not ideal
okay so I think we would all agree that
if you take someone who has the greatest
quality life they're the greatest person
they they're living life to the fullest
and yet they die prematurely at 50
they're struck down by an accident or by
a cancer diagnosis that they didn't live
long enough right they should have lived
longer I think we would all agree on
that I think similarly we would agree
that a person who lives a long life from
an Actuarial perspective you know
someone that lives into their 90s right
remember the median uh life expectancy
today in the United States for a male is
probably hovering around 80 or just
slightly below
so you take somebody who outlives that
by 15 years but
you know since they were in their 70s
they've been in a stage a stage of such
fragility that they haven't really been
able to enjoy anything or they've been
physically totally fine but cognitively
they're in such a state of decline or
both mind and body are fine but they're
miserable sons of [__] and they have
no meaningful relationships and
contribute nothing to the world well
maybe that's too long you know so so so
I just I don't I just don't think we
know the answer to that question I think
I think it's a it's a complex
integration of of of lifespan and health
span and that's why I think this health
span concept is so important and it's
something that for understandable
reasons because it's not as objective
um especially on the emotional side uh
is is largely ignored by the medical
community right the medical definition
of Health span is freedom from
disability and disease
that's a that's a that's a broad
definition and in my view not a helpful
definition because
are you as free from disability and
disease as you were when you were 20 I
mean you are
but if push comes to shove
the Jocko of today couldn't physically
do what the Jocko of you know 30 plus
years ago could do yeah you don't have
the recovery capacity right now you have
other things you have more wisdom right
I would bet that you're emotionally more
competent uh so so Health span has to
include these more nuanced ideas it
can't be just about disability and
disease
I have two
comments on this number one my my mom I
think it was last year my mom
was talking to me I was talking on the
phone and she said something along the
lines of like you know it's been a hard
you know my mom's my mom and dad are
getting in their 80s
late 70s 80s and so their friends were
all late 70s 80s and my mom was saying
you know it's been really hard for three
months four months whatever
um because
this person died this person died this
person died
and
I said hey Mom
I have gone to like so many funerals of
guys that were 27 32
41. 29
and all your friends lived a full happy
life I mean I I get it it's sad but be
thankful
that's part one uh the other thing I
want to say which is on a lighter note I
have a friend who had sleep apnea
and so we had the big machine
and he was in an unhappy marriage
and
he would rip the machine off at night
because he's a very aggressive hostile
you know form seal friend of mine and he
would rip the machine off at night and
his wife one time was trying to put it
back on him in the 90s batting our hands
away and they woke up in the morning and
and she said you know you need to let me
put my machine on you know put your
machine on you need to keep that on and
he says if I if it if I take it off just
leave it off and she says what do you
want me you'd want me just to leave it
off that's what you want me to do you
want me to do anything and he goes no
just let me die
[Laughter]
just let me die so that's the other end
of the spectrum I guess if you're in an
unhappy marriage that can be a that can
be a real bummer you know the other
thing uh
Have You Ever Seen The Show by the way I
want to go back I want to go back to the
first point you made because I really
I've been thinking a lot about that
lately just to take it back to Oliver
bergman's book
that's one of the framings that he talks
a lot about and it's this idea that
okay we're really struggling with this
idea that we're only here for 4 000
weeks like we as a species because we
have
that because of the sentient nature of
our Consciousness like we can really
process that in a way that an animal
can't right so they're not tormented by
their by their finitude we are
and he said look you know if you think
about it through the lens of cosmic
insignificance one none of us matter
right so let's just let's accept that
none of us matter but another framing is
the probability of any of us being here
is infinitesimal it can't even be
calculated it is so small like on the
day you were created like the
probability that that that that was the
day that your parents had sex and that
one sperm and that one egg managed to
meet to create you because if it was a
different sperm and or a different egg
it would be your brother it wouldn't be
you right
so the probability of your existence is
so remote we can't put a number on it
it's functionally zero
and he said you know look you think
about this another way to imagine this
is how grateful are you to have any
number of weeks
and again I still would argue that just
the way we're wired I think sometimes
it's too short right I don't think that
the 29 year old at the funeral
no matter how much they accomplish in
their 29 years you're still mourning on
some level
but you know if you make it to 80
and you die it is sad and I I just saw
somebody I sort of know reasonably well
die at 83 and he was one of those guys
you never thought could die so it was a
little
just it sort of it was it was just
upsetting in a way that it would be more
so than just anybody dying
um
but you know how amazing is it that any
of us might get four thousand weeks
stoked yeah
uh have you ever seen the show True
Detective okay
I watched the first one did you watch
the first one is it like a Netflix
series or something I don't know what's
on HBO HBO series The it's done two
three I think they've got three outputs
three out the first one's words like
three seasons yeah three seasons the
first one is really really good
especially the the first the early
episodes
anyways cops Mayhem going on but there's
a character in there called rust Cole
who's it's just an unbelievable
unbelievable character amazing character
uh just a really smart cynical guy who's
going through life and and at this one
point he's being investigated for crimes
there's a whole plot but he's being
investigated he's sitting down
interviewing there's there's cops that
are interviewing him
and he goes on this speech
speech which you can go watch on YouTube
but basically what he's saying is
he's talking about looking at DBS dead
bodies he's talking about looking at DBS
for 14 hours and he's going through
pictures and he and he's saying look it
doesn't matter if you're looking at
pictures or if you're looking at real or
if you see them just before they die or
just after they die you'll see that
in that last moment
they realized they they're okay because
they realize that everything that
they've loved and everything they've
hated and everything that they've lived
and everything that they've worried
about and everything they've been sad
about everything they've been happy
about
I think he says it's just a dream that
they had in their own head and they can
just let it all go
what do you think about that
hmm
foreign
I don't know I don't know if everyone
goes through that I don't know if
everybody experiences that right and
again it might depend on the time scale
right it might if if that's a statement
about the milliseconds prior to
expiration maybe there is something to
that and right we also just really don't
understand death I mean it really is a
vexing problem like we don't understand
the neurochemical process of death we
don't you know when you you know I'm
sure you've heard like all of these
people that have near-death experiences
come back and basically say the exact
same thing it's kind of hard to believe
they're just making this up or something
right like there's clearly something
really profound that's occurring
neurochemically in that in in those
final moments
um you know presumably for the people
who aren't like decapitated or something
like that whether it's in instantaneous
surprise death
um
but what I find interesting is that you
know like there are some people who I
hear talk about it so look we're all
dying we're all terminally dying so
we're all we all have a terminal disease
but there are some people for whom that
terminal disease is so apparent so I'm
sure you've heard Sam Harris talk about
The Hourglass uh have you heard about
this this is I I find this to be a very
powerful way to think about life and
death so
um all of our lives are represented by
an hourglass so when you're born
um there's you know all the sand is in
the top none is in the bottom and then
immediately the sand just starts flowing
but The Hourglass is opaque at the top
so you never actually know how much sand
remains in The Hourglass so we watch the
accumulation of sand in the bottom with
Clarity that's the years we're living
but we have no idea how much time
remains
now some people you know let's say
someone gets a cancer diagnosis and it's
a very bad cancer diagnosis so it's you
know you have pancreatic cancer and it's
it's spread to your liver
this is as close to a certain diagnosis
as possible you know you've got six to
nine months to live
what that means is now there's all that
opacity starts to become transparent in
the upper bulb and you see that there's
actually very little sand there
and as those days get closer and closer
to the end it becomes more and more
clear
and I would say that there are very
different reactions that people have to
that
um and maybe I spend a disproportionate
amount of time thinking about that
and wondering you know what's my
reaction going to be because I've seen
many people in that in that final stage
of sand and I've seen very different
reactions
um
but I would imagine that yes virtually
everybody if they're being honest with
themselves realizes that many of us
certainly I would be the heavyweight
champion of this probably spend time
worrying about things that don't justify
worry
um
I have a really I had a really weird
kind of horrible comparison to this I
was thinking of people that quit
people that quit whether they're
quitting you know in Seal training
whether they're quitting like you're
training with them and you see them just
quit and
you can see sure there's there's a
there's a moment of
they end up with the the shame and the
man you know should I stuck through it
but there's also like a Split Second
where they rationalize with themselves
and they say I don't have to do this
anymore that's what I think of when I
when I think of that like someone
getting their life is upon them and it's
the weight and you can't keep it
together anymore
I'm good
I hope I don't feel on my deathbed like
a quitter I really hope I don't that
would uh send me
um I know I just wouldn't appreciate
that I don't think at all
right
um
I'm gonna fast forward again the book is
410 pages long get it get it there's so
much good so much incredible information
in here
um
it's it's to me it's like a textbook as
well right it's a textbook because it is
so filled with with knowledge and and
information that look there's a bunch of
great stories in it but it's a textbook
to teach you this stuff and a reference
back to unless you're a medical doctor
you're not going to read this thing one
time and be like or like you know it's
cool for me because I've been listening
to you and known you for a long time so
I've I've heard you talk about these
things a lot so I get to read them and
now oh that's that's the definition I've
been missed so get the book
um
going a little bit here autophagy
represents the catabolic side of metal
and again I'm fast forward this is a
totally different section autophagy
represents the catabolic side of
metabolism when the cell stops producing
new proteins and instead begins to break
down old proteins and other cellular
structures into their amino acid
components using the scavenged materials
to build new ones it's a form of
cellular recycling cleaning out the
accumulated junk in the cell and
repurposing it for or disposing of it
instead of going to Home Depot to buy
more lumber and drywall screws the
cellular contractor scavages through the
debris from the house he just tore down
for spare material that he can reuse
either to build and repair the cell or
burn to produce energy autophagy's
essential life if it shuts down
completely the organism dies imagine if
you stopped taking out the garbage or
recycling your house would soon become
uninhabitable except instead of trash
bags trash bags this cellular cleanup is
carried out by specialized organelles
called lysosomes right
lysosomes which package up the old
proteins with other detrious including
pathogens and grind them down via
enzymes for reuse in addition the
lysosomes also break up and Destroy
things called Aggregates which are
clumps of damaged proteins that
accumulate over time protein aggregates
have been implicated in such diseases as
Parkinson's and Alzheimer's so to
getting rid of them is a good thing
impaired autophagy has also been linked
to alzheimer's disease related pathology
Parkinson's disease and other
neurodegenerative disorders mice who
lack one specific autophagy genes
succumb to neuro degeneration within two
or three months by cleansing our cells
of damaged proteins and other cellular
junk autophagy allows cells to run more
cleanly and efficiently and helps them
and helps make them more resistant to
stress as but as we get older autophagy
declines impaired autophagy is thought
to be an important driver of numerous
aging related phenotypes and ailments
such as neurodegeneration and Osteo
osteoarthritis
so this is how how long have people
known about autophagy this is something
look I went to high school in the
freaking 80s right but I remember some
stuff from biology I don't remember a
damn thing about autophagy
well I mean I think we'll put it this
way the Nobel Prize for the genetic
elucidation of how autophagy Works was
awarded relatively recently so long
after you and I were in high school okay
um so in that sense it's a little more
recent of an understanding
um
it's you know the million dollar
question because you can't read what you
just read and not ask okay how do I make
sure this is happening what do I need to
do to make sure I'm in the right balance
and of course there is a balance very
few things in biology are just a
straight line or a monotonic increasing
or decreasing function they're usually
used or inverted use not always and
we'll talk about some exceptions
potentially Fitness as an example of one
where there's no you or inverted you
it's just a straight up the more fit you
are the longer you live on average
period
hire your VO2 max longer your lifespan
but with autophagy there's a Goldilocks
principle you want to have the right
amount
and the the most important things that
are required to signal to autophagy are
generally reduction of nutrient in one
form or another now the two obvious ways
to do that one is obvious I guess one is
less obvious the most obvious way to do
that is fasting right so when you are
fasting after some point in time and
most people are surprised to learn we
don't know how long that is in humans
so we we know in mice very well how long
a mouse needs to fast before it you know
has a sufficient amount of autophagy
going on but the metabolism of mouse is
so much faster than ours that we can't
extrapolate so
um
you know in humans we could probably say
that a day is not long enough five days
is probably long enough no idea where
the balance is
um but what's interesting is at the
cellular level exercise is a really
important tool for autophagy because at
the cellular level when you are
exercising the cell is actually
experiencing enough of an energy deficit
that it triggers this process so this is
why exercise and fasting would probably
be the two most important tools we have
outside of pharmacology there's one drug
that may also you know be used for this
purpose but again it's a little too soon
to say at least in humans and so that
that's where we want to point people
what up that's another thing and I think
I'm gonna get to this later but you know
you talked about the chances of us being
here is so small this freaking system
that we're rolling around in is a damn
miracle I mean you think about this
stuff going on inside your body
something you've never thought about
before that we'd even know was going on
until pretty recently it's it's insane
what our body is doing all the time to
to to be here to be sitting here
surviving living
yeah my kids right now you know my boys
they're young of course and you know
them well um they're going through that
very predictable stage that uh five six
seven eight-year-olds go through which
is total obsession with dinosaurs and
sharks so pretty much all we're doing is
watching everything there is to watch on
YouTube about dinosaurs and sharks and
my the oldest of them the who's eight
like he knows every fact about these
things do you know that if a Spinosaurus
lost its spine he would still be able to
survive because I was like I don't even
know what a spine is like I knew what a
T-Rex was and a Triceratops like I just
didn't I don't have any recollection of
this he knows all of them and you know
it if you think about it like how many
millions yeah so let's just say like 30
million years ago you had these things
roaming the Earth with their little tiny
P brains
and to think that like we're here today
like this is unbelievable and we I love
talking about Evolution and natural
selection with them like I really enjoy
talking about it yesterday my my son was
debating with me and he might be right I
think he's wrong but he was trying to
convince me that the great white shark
is has evolved from the Megalodon and
the Megalodon did not really go extinct
and I'm like I don't think that's true
buddy I think the Megalodon is extinct
and maybe the great white you know you
just but but these things are kind of
unbelievable and even at the simplest
level I still can't believe it works
like just at the level of a great white
shark or you know never mind something
that's as sophisticated as we are yeah
when when you got all this act like it
was just sitting here thinking about
your kids right and I was thinking about
Jiu Jitsu the other day Jiu Jitsu is
evolving it's so much faster right now
than it did 30 years ago
and it's because more people are
participating but it's more because the
information is just readily accessible
so you can go on YouTube and you can
learn all this stuff and
I heard an interview I think it was I
think Lex Friedman was interviewing
um uh the chess player the greatest
chess player Gary Casper yes he was
interviewing Casper off and he he asked
Casper off if he could meet if he could
beat Magnus Carlson and kasperoff said
no
but what was interesting there's two
things that he said number one he said
because I thought
you could beat him of course because
you've been playing longer and you're
like the guy he said I can't think as
fast as I used to so there's the
greatest chess player in the world
and he's saying no I can't do what I
used to do
which is crazy because there's no
physical thing we this was such it was
like one of the first times I ever
accepted the fact that the cognitive
decline is a real thing
that was number one number two he said
he he he said Magnus he has all my moves
and he's had all my moves and so he
didn't have to create any of my moves he
just got them and so now he's creating
he's building on what's already there
so when we advance in medicine let's say
are we advancing at a faster rate now
than we did 50 years ago because
everyone's just the information's all
there I mean now we've got AI that can
pull up all this old information you
could do studies is it are we getting
better are we getting faster
yeah in some ways I mean the the concept
of course that you're describing is the
most important concept of our Evolution
right and I think one fun way to think
about this actually life was over a
couple weeks ago when we were having
dinner and and sitting around you know
our job was making sure that none of the
food got burnt on the grill so while we
were sitting there this I posed this
thought experiment to him which was
which I'll pose to you now so
you you know what you know it's 2023
this is everything you know
I'm going to put you in a time machine
and send you back
2 000 years now make it let's make it
five thousand years here we're gonna
send you back five thousand years
how much can you bend the Arc of
civilization with the knowledge you have
now
five thousand years ago yeah well that
depends if I don't just get it you know
die
let's assume I put you back in the
appropriate part of you know the five
thousand years ago I'd have to put you
in Egypt to be in the center of
civilization right so I'm going to put
you back in Egypt I'm going to color
your skin the right color I'm going to
make you look like you're Egyptian right
so you're not gonna have the knowledge
that I have you have the knowledge you
have now but let's be clear
you don't have any more than the
knowledge you have now right
so you know what 2023 looks like
and you're in 3000 BC can you bend the
Ark of the universe in some areas where
let's talk about it well I can tell you
straight up like because I'm sitting
here thinking if they want I would
probably provide little to no value in
medicine now look there's one area you
could I could I could say collect
cleanliness right exactly sanitation is
the only thing I can think of where if
you put me back in time I could make a
difference now that assumes people
listen because remember and I write a
whole chapter not a I write a whole
section about semelvice
he came up with this idea first and they
put him in an insane asylum where he
died so you also have to assume people
would listen but outside of that man
yeah I got nothing to offer yeah you
could imagine you standing there you'd
sound like a prophet we're gonna have
these things they're going to be called
iPhones and you're gonna and they're
gonna have this thing called the
internet like what I mean the point is
Connecticut Yankee and King Arthur's
Court you remember that book no yeah
it's like this guy goes back from
Connecticut Yankee he goes to King Arts
Court one of the things he does he he
knows when the uh the eclipse is gonna
happen and so he's like I'm gonna blot
out the Sun and oh my gosh but uh okay
sorry continue yeah so so my point is
like all of the the modern nature of the
world we have today is all predicated on
knowledge transfer it's codification and
transfer of knowledge and until that
happened like we were in the dark ages
for hundreds of thousands of years and
then the reason I think we're you know
technology is increasing exponentially
is due to to that it's and these have
fed off each other right so the the more
we can codify knowledge presumably
starting with the printing press the
more we could get to the point where we
could generate knowledge that could do
all these other things so to answer your
question
um
I think it's non-linear I think there
are some spikes so I'll give you an
example
um
you know most things that people think
about and most people understand Moore's
Law which is kind of like the PA you
know it's about an 18-month doubling uh
or halving depending on how you look at
it uh you know semiconductors you know
so sort of Chip size and incapacity
well there's actually been one thing in
medicine that has taken a step function
faster than Moore's law in its genetic
sequencing so when the first human
genome was sequenced in about the year
the cost of sequencing
went down at a Moore's law rate until
about 2006 and then it just went boom
just dropped to nothing and now it's
continuing at Moore's law rate but from
a way lower Baseline and that big drop
was uh High throughput sequencing
next-gen High throughput sequencing so
like that's one example where
there's been a step function change in
recent years in the past you know 15
years that has made at least genetic
sequencing
you know completely transformational
but you know what it hasn't translated
to a huge impact in health so it's been
a big scientific breakthrough that
hasn't really translated to a huge
impact in health
um I think there are other areas where I
think we are starting to see areas where
I'm optimistic so in cancer Therapeutics
I think
it's been largely
pretty unsuccessful
for you know 75 years and then in the
last 10 years there's been a pretty big
Improvement in harnessing the immune
system now we're still in totally
nascent days
but I would say and this is probably a
conservative estimate
eight percent of people who would have
died even 25 years ago are living today
with metastatic cancer
and and we made zero progress from 1950
to 2000 on metastatic solid organ cancer
and and so now we've you know so we're
moving we're moving yeah that's good
um your initial question about what I
would do it five thousand years ago and
I was like well there's one area like I
know jiu jitsu and you don't need
anything for that because like look I
know about weapons but I couldn't I
don't know how to make the metal to make
a weapon right I know there's I know you
can take like bat guano and make
freaking gunpowder somehow right but I
wouldn't be able to pull it off but I
know Jitsu I'd be I could I could jack
some people up I'd put together an army
we'd take over the world I can say that
well what kind of weapons were they
using 5000 years ago what did the
Egyptian armies use my guess is Spears
yeah sure on the trebuchet yeah I don't
know if I yeah I could show the
trebuchet like we could we could start
if they didn't have I guess if they
didn't have bow and arrow yet we could
get the bow and arrow Out start using
that crossbow yeah crossbow but again
like figure I'd have to go through the
procedure concept here is that military
advancement would be the most important
thing that we could bring to us as
civilization well that's the most
important thing I could bring I think
you would be a much better person to
send back in time I would make things
much worse
it would be much smarter to send Peter
Tia back not Jocko we just end up in
some weird war like freaking dystopian
time right now but but but you know so
let's say you sent me back right and
let's say by some miracle I could
convince people to wash their hands that
would have an enormous impact but you
know what I couldn't do I couldn't build
a microscope yeah I was going to say you
could build you I mean could you build a
scalpel
it wouldn't be as much value they would
probably already have it it's the
anesthetic I wouldn't be able to build
ether I wouldn't be able to make ether
and that was the big breakthrough and by
the way that didn't happen until the
late 19th century can you believe they
used to cut people
surgically until just 140 years ago
without 150 years ago you would undergo
surgery like White Knuckle in it yeah
damn they were hard back then huh the
people just pass out or you think they
just got through it
um so it's totally it's really
interesting when you go back and read
about surgical what was prized in a
surgeon pre-anesthesia versus post
pre-anesthesia the only thing that
mattered was how fast you were damn like
literally it didn't matter how accurate
it was like can you operate fast they
used to operate in front of crowds yeah
that was actually not that was you would
even see operating theaters that exist
probably in up until the 1940s or 50s
who's going
uh usually students and other people
there to observe but it's not just like
it's not Friday night yeah yeah yeah no
it's like the medical students okay that
makes sense do they still do that right
uh I mean not in a formal theater okay
you know but you but you're probably
watching videos
yeah look when I was in when I was in
medical school I I I'd have vhs's of
procedures that I would watch
so that I you know I didn't I didn't
want to go in and try to like assist on
my first one without having watched it a
bunch yeah that's crazy there was a guy
in ramadi Army Captain Awesome guy and
he would sit back like go out on Ops and
he would run a camera the whole time a
video camera from his Humvee and then
he'd go back and just sit there and
watch and he'd be like oh yeah he would
know that little what that door looked
like what that courtyard looked like
that's squared away you know that's why
why would you not do that freaking
awesome all right I'm gonna fast forward
a little bit in the 1950s
a surgeon in Topeka Kansas named Samuel
Zellman was operating on a patient whom
he knew personally because the man was
an aide in the hospital where he worked
he'd known for a fact the man did not
drink any alcohol so he was surprised to
find out that his liver was packed with
fat just like one of my patients decades
later this man did in fact drink a lot a
lot of Coca-Cola
Zellman knew that he consumed a
staggering quantity of soda as many as
20 bottles or more in a single day
these were the older smaller Coke
bottles not the Super Size we have now
but still Zellman estimated that his
patient was taking an extra 1600
calories per day on top of his already
ample meals among his colleagues zelman
noted he was distinguished for his
appetite his curiosity peaked zelman
recruited 19 other obese but
non-alcoholic subjects for a clinical
study he tested their blood and urine
and conducted a liver biopsies on them a
serious procedure performed with a
serious needle all the subjects bore
some sign or signs of impaired liver
function in a way that eerily in a way
eerily similar to the well-known stages
of liver damage seen in Alcoholics this
syndrome was often noted but little
understood it was typically attributed
to alcoholism or hepatitis when it began
to be seen in teenagers in the 1970s and
80s worried doctors warned of a hidden
epidemic of teenage binge drinking
but alcohol was not to blame in 1980 a
team at the Mayo Clinic dubbed this hit
hero unnamed disease
unnamed disease non-alcoholic Stadium
hepatitis am I saying that right
hepatitis the Idaho hepatitis or Nash
since then it is blossomed into a global
plague more than one in four people on
this planet have some degree of Nash or
its precursor known as non-alcoholic
fatty liver disease
how disturbing is that
yeah
the hidden epidemic
they thought initially that kids were
just binge drinking and that's why they
had this fatty liver but it was just
because our freaking diet was heinous
yeah in fact I think I opened this
chapter talking about
um a patient that I you know this is
when I was an intern and I was assisting
on a procedure this was a patient who
had colon cancer he was there to get the
right part of his hemicolon removed and
you know we and my job was to pre-op him
so that meant I had to go and ask him
all the mundane questions among them is
how much do you drink and that's
relevant from an anesthesia perspective
right so you've got to know if
somebody's a big drinker he claimed to
not drink at all so fine so we get into
the OR and again my job is to pretty
much just retract and suction that's it
I'm a lowly intern at this point and uh
we we open them up and like the biggest
fat liver just pops out of this guy and
the attending surgeon is upset at me
thinking clearly I didn't even do the
one thing I was supposed to do which was
figure out if this guy was a drinker
um and of course it turned out he wasn't
and you know none of us really thought
much about it at the time and but you
know this was more than 20 years ago and
we now realized today that the nafldi
and Nash are the leading indication for
liver transplant in the United States
and this chapter is called the crisis of
abundance because this is just too much
Coca-Cola too much freaking crap
which is crazy right like that's where
we're at that's what's going on
yeah I mean let's let's start with the
Positive spin going back to our
evolutionary discussion well okay
I like it all right so
you talked a minute ago about how
amazing it is that we're here
and I assumed you were mostly referring
to humans
um it's obviously true of all species
but but it is true like we are we're in
a league of Our Own
but what puts us in the league of our
own is it our strength no
even your strength right no is it our
speed no I mean it's it's one thing that
catapulted us out of the swamp and
passed every other species pre or
current and that is our brains
our brain is the defining feature of our
species
and
we pay a price if you will to have a
brain like ours and it's a metabolic
price
so your brain takes up two percent of
your body weight
and yet it consumes 25
of your metabolic rate 25 of the
calories you eat go to feed that two
percent of your body weight
so
how could we possibly get where we are
without evolving a very elaborate system
to make sure you never run out of energy
and that's what we had to do right and
so and if you by the way if you look at
primates today right these would be our
nearest evolutionary relatives they
don't have this capacity
right when you over feed primates they
get more muscular
when you overfeed humans we get fatter
and again in light of all we're going to
talk about that's not a good thing but
from an evolutionary perspective it's
important because muscle is a lousy
source of energy
fat is not fat is a wonderful source of
energy
so
basically we were the we were like the
only electric car to show up with a huge
battery everybody else basically had an
electric car with a mini battery and
that meant they couldn't drive very far
we were the only ones that could drive
all over the place
so
if you think about it up until a couple
hundred years ago
those you know tens of thousands of
years of evolution served us really
really well we were incredibly active
food was incredibly scarce
we didn't have natural we didn't have
unnatural light and we didn't really
have chronic stress we only had acute
stress so you've got acute but no
chronic stress no you know unnatural
light scarce food and you're active as
hell
and by active as hell I don't mean we
were like running marathons a day but
like but you're we're more Gathering
you're moving around yeah and we
conserved energy like it's a bit of a
myth to say that humans were like
constantly hoofing it we looked for
every reason to not move an inch because
of the scarcity problem right like you
never wanted to wait but you put all
those things together and we were in
perfect energy balance
and then you know a hundred years ago or
so all that started to change when we we
tried to solve a problem so the problem
was
hey we don't want to be in farms anymore
like we want to do other things we we
want to set up a society where people
can do things other than be in charge of
growing their own food
so we're going to centralize that we
have to be able to scale that problem so
we have to be able to grow food at huge
scale we have to be able to preserve
food to be able to ship it and
distribute it
we should really make it taste good as
well you know start to get into the
hedonic side of this
um
and
you basically arrive at this thing
called the standard American diet
and it you know none of those things I
mentioned that were part of the
optimization State involved make it not
harmful like that was neither a goal nor
a thing to be avoided it was just it
wasn't considered it was how do you make
it cheap how do you make it abundant how
do you make it non-perishable and how do
you make it taste good those were
basically the criteria
and so what we have today is the
standard American diet and so when you
take our genes and superimpose them on
the standard American diet it's the
crisis of overabundance and for most of
us that requires being deliberate
because if we just let our brains run
rampant
I mean for most of us we end up in an
unhealthy State yeah because part of our
part of the evolution that we made was
to want to eat all this stuff that
tastes good and that's just you have to
fight against that absolutely I mean if
you think about it like you know it's
not an accident that we like sweet
things I mean that was a very important
characteristic to have right I mean we
depending on which which ancestral tribe
you look at I mean some of them got up
to 20 25 of their calories from berries
and honey
I mean we were we really wanted to know
what what sweet was that was a very
important trait in fact I mean I I think
I write about it very briefly I you know
one of these things I'm sure you can
relate to this Jocko is you're writing a
book you sometimes forget the first
version versus the published version
because it's been hacked down so like
the first version of this book was 200
000 words what people are reading here
is a hundred and twenty thousand words
which is still to your point a very long
book but the 200 000 word book
that was A Treatise and I think some of
this got I think there's a much longer
section I wrote about the evolution of
an enzyme called uricase and
um how
basically there was a period of time in
which we we also couldn't get very fat
um by we I mean Apes that became us
right so these Apes basically left
Africa went to Europe Ice Age comes and
they're only the subset of the Apes that
developed a mutation to preferentially
store fat out of fructose survived
because they could eat enough fructose
in this fall
to fatten up for the lean times during
the winter and the ones who couldn't
develop that mutation died off the
surviving ones came back to Africa they
basically became the precursor to us as
humans so again very valuable set of
mutations up until you know the last
0.001 of our time on this planet
that's an amazing system this freaking
flesh bot we're running around in isn't
it really it's nuts speaking of that I'm
gonna fast forward here scientists have
been exploring the medical Mysteries of
the human heart for almost as long as
poets have been probing its metaphorical
depth
s it is a wondrous organ a tireless
muscle that pumps blood around the body
every moment of Our Lives it pounds hard
when we're exercising slows down when we
sleep even micro adjusts its rate
between beats a hugely important
phenomenon called heart rate variability
and when it stops we stop our vascular
network is equally miraculous a web of
veins arteries and capillaries that if
stretched out and laid end to end would
wrap around the earth more than twice
about 60 000 miles if you're keeping
score so that's each individual human so
I have that yep
are these like microscopic that's why
yeah so so if you think about it like
coming out of your heart is one huge
artery called the aorta and then it
immediately
um splits so it comes it has three
things that hop off it okay so they're
major arteries but if you trace the like
the the major arteries they become
smaller and smaller arterioles that
become capillaries that become venules
that become veins tiny veins that become
bigger veins and bigger veins that
become the two major veins that flow
back into the heart so what it's saying
is yeah you take all of those things
because once you're at the capillary
level you have a whole bunch of these
things in parallel it's not just a
Serial process so it's take all of that
out and yeah it's insane each blood
vessel is by the way yeah not not to
just harp on this idea
this is one of those things that I don't
think gets enough attention in terms of
like how that even works like we like
the best and brightest Engineers
Material Science Engineers on this
planet can't come close to making
materials that can do this because if
you think about it how does something
that small stay patent it shouldn't like
we we can't even figure out a way to
make an artificial coronary artery
like if someone needs a coronary artery
bypassed we can only use their native
blood vessel from somewhere else and
that's a an artery that's like a
millimeter and a half wide in diameter
it's even visible to the eye we still
can't come close to making something
that small let alone the microscopic
stuff
uh it going on same path through each
individual blood vessel is a Marvel of
Material Science and Engineering capable
of expanding and expanding and
Contracting dozens of times per minute
allowing vital substances to pass
through its membranes and accommodating
huge swings in fluid pressure with
minimal fatigue no material created by
man can even come close to matching this
if one vessel is injured others regrow
to take its place ensuring continuous
blood flow throughout the body then it's
interesting uh my route here was
F1 engineering is F1 car engineering is
like a miracle and but
compared to the human hand the human
heart to the human brain like it's just
not even
it's nothing it's a joke yeah it's
pretty amazing how our bodies manage to
work
so my other note here
was
what is what is it that we do we know
what we don't know what is the spark
that makes life
because we can't create an amoeba right
now can we
do we know what we're missing do we can
we can we identify what it is that we
don't know
well I mean I I should clarify this
um
there there are some ways to create
synthetic life
um at the at a very like an algae or
something like that there is some type
of synthetic biology that can be done
um so we can take
no algae we can take the material that
is in algae no I shouldn't I shouldn't
say that here's what we can't do let's
so going with algae which is really
simple right
so what makes algae special or makes
plants special for that matter is
photosynthesis
um
we can't in a black box make
photosynthesis
in other words we can't
in a black box make something that takes
carbon dioxide
and Light
and fixes carbon atoms and spits out
oxygen and water like we can't do that
um
you know it depends okay so so your
question is a bit difficult to answer
because
we can you could argue
we can take an egg and a sperm
and merge those together using in vitro
fertilization and we can grow that out
yeah I get that
um
but we're starting with the perfect
genetic material at the outset like
we're starting with a perfect egg and a
perfect sperm and we inject them and
both those things are alive right when
you say they're alive I don't know I
mean I guess this that's a bit of a
semantic question right what I mean how
do we Define alive uh
it's not bad meaning if you take an egg
and you put it out in the you know on
the shelf and hit it with a hammer and
put it in the sun it's not going to work
anymore right that's right yeah same
thing with a sperm yeah so there's
something there's some attribute that
they have that I believe we would call
life it's alive yeah there's there's
yeah I mean I guess you could say it's
cellular respiration would probably be
the definition or the the line I think I
think cellular respiration would be this
cellular definition of life
so which me which is metabolic right so
it's a metabolic definition of life and
we can't create that no do we know what
it is that we're what we're missing do
we understand that is a chemical thing
well I mean what we understand why it's
happening we don't like we can't make a
mitochondria yeah that's what's so
freaking crazy right yeah we can't make
the engine that drives cellular
respiration
someone working on that
I mean we're not even working on that
what we're working on is how do we
minimize the damage to our mitochondria
right because if you think about aging
there are Hallmarks to aging I list all
nine of them in the book right and
I think one of the most important or
significant Hallmarks of Aging is
mitochondrial dysfunction
so as we age our mitochondria become
less and less functional so while as
interesting it would as it would be to
see if we could make mitochondria I
would settle for can we figure out how
to
stop or decline stop the decline of and
or reverse the decline of mitochondrial
dysfunction
and the good news is we we have some
interventions that do exercise does
right like exercise clearly blunts that
effect and if you take a person with
type 2 diabetes which would be kind of
the Hallmark state of mitochondrial
dysfunction and you get that person
exercising like crazy and their diabetes
goes away like you've improved the state
of their mitochondria absolutely full
stop so we have functional tests that
are usually exercise based to determine
mitochondrial Health
um but shy of that like it's not like
we've got a drug that we can give
somebody to to Tinker with that system
or to take an 80 year old and give them
20 year old mitochondria just not
happening
oh yeah we got a long ways to go don't
we I think very long and in a way that's
kind of what like
you know there's there's an entire topic
I don't touch on in this book and it's a
very deliberate decision right and and
and it's it's basically the entire topic
of the Sci-Fi of anti-aging
right like so so in some ways I'm sure
there are some people who will read my
book and come across and and come to the
end of the book and do like
where's all the cool [__] Oh you mean
like uh cryo yeah or just like like
where you freeze yourself yeah or like
where's all the you know cellular
engineering stuff and where's all the
you know the highfalutin really cool
ideas that are you know we're going to
become immortal and um and the reason I
don't write about that stuff is
um one I think enough other people are
but but more than that I think that
I'm trying to write the operating manual
for what you can do today and if nothing
else even if any of those other things
come to be viable In Our Lifetime and I
don't think they will
this would still be your hedge right
this is the what you can do today like
why does exercise matter why would
exercise add a decade to your life and
more importantly even if it didn't even
if you know I often said this I think I
even make the point in the book even if
you told me exercise was going to
shorten My Life by a year it would still
be worth it based on the dramatic
expansion and quality of life and if
you're I think most people if they
really think about it they don't care as
much about length of life outside of
those extreme states nobody wants to die
at 50. no matter how good their life is
um
but if you say to somebody do you care
if you live to 78 versus 88 if you told
them that the 88 was going to be 15
years of poor quality and the 78 was
going to be six months of poor quality
I'm not sure I know anybody who wouldn't
take the 78.
so
um
as it bringing it back to the
mitochondria like we might not know for
a very long time how to rebuild those
things
um but we sure as hell know how much
exercise will give you better
mitochondria more of them and better
ones
speaking of high school science I was
taking my high school science class and
I remember it was in I think it was in
chemistry and like we finally got this
something where my teacher was like we
don't know why this happens
and it was the first time in my
Scholastic career and I was like well
you know I was sitting there doodling or
doing something he said we don't
actually know why this happens and I was
like wait a second what he's like we
don't know
it should have been the thing that
sparked me to enter physics and become a
scientist what is that I was like damn
that's messed up you know Chief
knucklehead to try and think oh I could
go try and figure that out uh
interesting fast forward kids are great
for that right I mean the the amount of
stuff that like you know because kids
are they just don't care they'll just
ask questions and they'll keep asking
and they'll keep asking and they'll keep
asking you a question were you where
you've gotten to I don't know yet oh you
have tons tons oh yeah all the time yeah
my especially the boys right because
they're at that age where they're my
daughter now just doesn't ask me too
many questions she knows that you don't
know anything
but but the boys love asking like you
know all those kinds of questions yeah
that's good all right
um fast forward a little bit Richard
Nixon declared a national War again I'm
skipping through like massive chunks of
this book go get the book
I don't think I'm doing a good job of
skipping Parts I think I'm skipping too
much but anyways that's what we're doing
Richard Nixon declared a national war on
cancer in 1971. initially the Hope was
that cancer would be cured within the
next five years in time for the
bicentennial
you want to talk about some presidential
promises gone wrong good job
yet it remains doubly undefeated in 1976
and still by the time I finished medical
school in 2001 and today for all intents
and purposes despite well over a hundred
billion spent on Research via the
National Cancer Institute plus many
billions more from Private Industry and
public Charities despite all the pink
ribbons and yellow bracelets and
literally millions of published papers
on the pub Med database cancer is the
second leading cause of death in the
United States right behind heart disease
together these two conditions account
for almost one in every two American
deaths the difference is that we
understand the Genesis and progression
of heart disease fairly well and we have
some effective tools tools with which to
prevent and treat it as a result
mortality rates from cardiovascular
disease
have dropped by two-thirds since the
middle of the 20th century but cancer
still kills Americans at almost exactly
the same rate it did 50 years ago
so
cancer horrible
that being said I read one time
that nurse they surveyed nurses
how would you want to die
and
the nurses chose cancer
the and and I guess it was
what they said was you have time you can
say goodbye you can set things up
correctly
that's what they thought
um
I had a friend die of cancer
pancreatic cancer how old
48 something like that
uh very very fit triathlete type guy and
and
I remember I didn't I Googled it it was
it was early internet so this was
probably
it was not really good but it was like
2000 and let's say 2010 2011 2012
something around that and one of my
other friends called and said hey we
just got you know he has cancer he's got
this kind of cancer pancreatic cancer I
Google it
pancreatic cancer cancer survival rate
after two years zero percent something
that maybe a survival rate after five if
it spread yeah zero percent well overall
it's like less than five percent for
everybody yeah uh it's the most lethal
cancer along with a certain type of
brain cancer he died
four months later I mean it was he must
have not known about it until late which
I know you get into in the book but uh
yeah it was awful what it did to this
incredibly healthy guy in a very short
period of time which is what surprised
me when these nurses said
I think cancer would be the best way but
I guess you have that time to make
things right
I'm really I don't know why you're
telling that story really reminds me of
um another one of these memories I have
from residency so
um I was doing a rotation in the ER so
as a surgical resident you will do
typically one month a year as the
surgical lead of the ER so you're in the
ER taking care of everything that walks
in but they're they're driving to you
the surgical cases
and um so that means you know anything
that needs to be stitched up sewn up
drained pus this that and the other
thing put a chest tube in you're kind of
doing all those things
so I'm in the I'm in the surgical wing
of the of the ER at Hopkins
and uh this young girl comes in and
um
God she was she was she was probably 21.
um she's her mom brought her in and she
was just complaining of back pain and it
had been like pretty significant but it
sounds like you've been going on for
weeks
um and she finally you know they just
came to the ER which again is kind of an
unusual place to go for back pain you
normally would go and see your doctor or
go and get a referral to PT or something
like that and
um you know I examined her and she's
really in a lot of pain and and I
remember there's a handful of things you
just sort of remember and I remember
like just beautiful beautiful
um completely healthy looking 21 year
old but there was no question that as I
pressed on her spine like it was really
quite tender
um and so I suspected maybe she had a
fracture like it's possible she didn't
report any trauma
um and who knows like I just assumed
look either she's got some fracture
there because there's some tenderness or
you know more likely maybe she's you
know really had some serious disc
disease and um
so you know for a fracture the test you
want to do is a CT scan not an MRI at
the time it was too it would take too
long to get the MRI so I figured look
let's do the CT scan
um if nothing else we don't see a
fracture we would probably just admit
her for pain and then you know she would
get you know she'd go to the you know
Orthopedic floor or something they would
do an MRI and figure out okay so anyway
to make a monster story do the CT scan
she's got metastatic pancreatic cancer
and it's spread to her bone and that's
why she's in so much pain
and I mean
it's it's again it's just one of those
moments where
like I can't believe this is happening
and how do I go and tell this girl and
her mom and her mom looks like she's you
know 45 like her mom's a a young woman
and
um and at that point she's going to be
admitted to not a surgical floor because
this is not a surgical case when the
cancer has spread she's going to be
admitted to a medical service to a
medical oncology service
um and you know they're gonna they're
gonna palliate her at this point they're
probably they might give her some
ineffective chemo but it's mostly
palliation
um
and I just um you know I just remember
not wanting to let her go like I just
had this sense of like God I wish I
wish I could admit her to a surgical
service
which of course was made no sense at all
right
[Music]
um
but
you know pancreatic cancer is awful I
mean it is awful it's you know it's it's
it's one of those cancers that gives
cancer a bad name
um and it's interesting that there's a
subset of pancreatic cancer that is
curable
so most of them
um are what are called exocrine
pancreatic cancer so the adenocarcinoma
of the pancreas
um so the pancreas is made up just
broadly speaking five percent of the
pancreas is endocrine that's the part
that secretes insulin and glucagon and
these peptides and then 95 of it is
exocrine it secretes the digestive
juices that's where the majority of
cancers arise and those are the cancers
that are essentially uniformly fatal but
every once in a while someone will get a
pancreatic cancer of the endocrine
system
like a glucagonoma or an insulinoma
believe it or not those cancers are
almost always survivable provided you
don't let them Fester forever
do you know who died of a pancreatic
endocrine tumor unnecessarily
no Steve Jobs
how'd that happen
so he was diagnosed with
um
a tumor and for reasons I don't I was
never involved in his care of course I
didn't I never knew the guy but based on
everything I've read he just decided he
was going to beat this treatment he was
going to beat his cancer with
juice and stuff like that so he went way
too long without getting treatment and
by the time he did get treatment the
cancer had spread to his liver
it was a bit too late they treated him
but ultimately he needed a liver
transplantation which is a very unusual
procedure you would do you normally
would never do a liver transplant for
cancer that has spread to the liver but
you could do it for this type of cancer
but even then it was too little too late
and he ultimately died as a result so
um it's sort of one of the great ironies
right which is you have this person who
you know had such a remarkable impact on
the world
gets diagnosed with the cancer but gets
really lucky in that he gets diagnosed
with a cancer that is survivable but you
know for reasons of his own just felt
that he could sort of beat this without
traditional treatment but you know the
people I've spoken to and I do know
people who were involved in his care and
they've all said that had he undergone
the standard treatment for that
immediately uh you know he'd probably
still be alive
is this is this just crazy ego
I don't know I mean I again having never
met the guy knowing nothing about him
you know literally only having read a
bunch of his biographies you know his
biographers would certainly speculate
um and and they have
um
but I don't understand yeah and at a
certain point your doctors are telling
you and then you're you know I'm sure he
went and got a second opinion and a
third opinion and they're all like hey
bro
you need to get this taken care of and
he's like no I'm good pass me the carrot
juice yeah damn
that's insane I did not know that
um
fast forward a little bit important to
bring this up the final and perhaps most
important tool in our anti-cancer
Arsenal is early aggressive screening
this remains a controversial topic but
the evidence is overwhelming that
catching cancer early is almost always
net beneficial
unfortunately the same problem I
encountered in residency applies today
too many cancers are detected too late
and after they've after they've grown
and spread
very few treatments work against these
Advanced cancers in most cases outside
of the few cancers that respond to
immunotherapies the best we can hope for
is delay is to delay death slightly the
10-year survival rate for patients with
metastatic cancers virtually the same
now as it was 50 years ago zero
we do we need to do more than hope for
novel therapies when cancers are
detected early in stage one survival
rates Skyrocket this is partly because
of simple math the early stage cancers
compromise fewer total cancerous cells
or sorry comprise fewer total cancerous
cells with fewer mutations and thus
are more vulnerable to treatment with
drugs that we do have including some
immunotherapies I would go so far as to
argue that early detection is our best
hope for radically reducing cancer
mortality
where does the resistance come from
I think it comes from an overly
simplistic view so let's take a step
back right you alluded to kind of
medicine 2.0 earlier and we you know I
the one of the first chapters in the
book is kind of devoted to explaining
the difference between medicine 2.0 and
3.0 and by the way it's the underlying
that's the underlying theme of the book
is that medicine 2.0 is hey we treat
what hits us medicine 3.0 is or sorry
medicine 2.0 is we catch the eggs that
are dropping from this from the building
medicine 3.0 as we go and find out who's
dropping these eggs and we get them to
stop so it's it's prevention
interdiction early interdiction early
detection that's what medicine 3.0 is
yeah so as you go deeper and deeper into
that you realize that one of the
Hallmarks of medicine 2.0 is an
appropriate Reliance on randomized
control trials
so again
um if you take a step back and go into
the medicine 1.0 days which was
basically
all of human history up until the late
19th century
um we were just making stuff up like
every everything was just sort of made
up everything was a story right I mean I
mean if you go back and really think
about it like that's how we made sense
of the world around us we are
storytelling creatures and we had to
make sense of the Sun the moon the stars
Darkness bad things happening every you
know how why is Johnny sick it must be
the bad humors must be the bad air
um clear it's getting darker than light
clearly these things are revolving
around us right so you can't fault us
for doing this but once the scientific
method
was really developed
this happens in the sort of middle of
the 17th century
um
you fast forward a couple hundred years
and we now start coming up with this
idea of doing experiments and this
becomes very very important in fact it
becomes the Cornerstone of medicine 2.0
and these experiments which everyone has
heard of called randomized controlled
experiments have
um
an area where they work really well but
they have blind spots so they work
really well when the interventions are
simple
and when the outcomes are going to occur
relatively quickly so a good example of
a randomized control trial is you know
does giving kids you know this vaccine
for measles prevent measles and you you
know even that's too complicated let's
take something simpler like does using
this antibiotic when you have an ear
infection reduce the risk of perforated
eardrums and long-term complications you
would take a bunch of kids and you would
randomize some of them to the antibiotic
and some of them to a placebo and you
would follow them and you would very
quickly see that there's a difference
and because they've been randomized
you've eliminated the bias this is the
magic of randomization it takes out bias
we otherwise can't eliminate bias fully
um
randomized control trials don't work
very well in nutrition because the
intervention is way too complicated it's
very difficult to tell a group of people
to go and do something nutrition wise
and have them be perfectly compliant for
five years and come back and compare it
to another group of people we can talk
about some examples of where that's work
but nevertheless it's challenging
there's that time course
so
even with the best of intentions the
randomized controlled experiment has a
problem which is it's only giving you
average information so
you put n people into the system they're
all different
you you run an intervention and you get
an average outcome
that's valuable information at the
population level it's not very valuable
information at the individual level
any individual that went into the
computation of that average could be
quite distinct there's quite a variance
to that
so bringing this back to cancer
screening
the real issue with cancer screening is
the the technologies that are typically
debated all have strengths and
weaknesses all have limitations all have
blind spots
and if you look at this in a very simple
way and you factor in dollars
you might make the case that you know
the only way it's Justified to catch a
cancer is if it saves money in the long
run
and that's kind of true in a way but
it's based on a couple of problems that
I'm not really here to write about so
I'm only here to write about the
individual I'm not here to write about
the policy and the reason being is I
think the policy side is broken so we
have artificial costs associated with
health care in the United States so none
of the dollars that we talk about in the
U.S are real dollars it's just funny
money they're made up numbers and it's
gotten a lot worse in the past
12 years so 12 years
the US government made a deal with the
devil and the deal was
you promote
um
the Affordable Care Act
we will never negotiate with you on
price again
to the drug companies so we just pay
much more for that furthermore we have
this two-tiered system of for-profit
not-for-profit in health care
so all of a sudden unlike everybody else
we have a for-profit health care System
which just drives up cost remarkably
so you know that's a whole separate
discussion which I'm not interested in
at the moment I'm actually asking the
question what should you do what should
your wife do to maximize their odds of
not getting cancer or if you get cancer
beating it so in that situation we have
to stack screening modalities so let's
take breast cancer as one example and
then we'll take prostate as another
example and use those two because
they're those are the second and third
leading causes of cancer death so it's
lung
uh breast and prostate colon pancreatic
those are the top five those five
cancers are responsible for more than 50
percent of cancer deaths in the United
States
so the standard you know thinking on
breast cancer historically has been
mammography and a mammogram is a decent
test but it's not a great test because
no single test is a great test a
mammogram has like a
roughly 90 sensitivity and 85 percent
specificity so sensitivity means How
likely is it to see cancer if cancer is
present
so the answer is about 90 percent
the 85 percent specificity means How
likely is it to say no cancer is there
if indeed no cancer is there 85 that
might sound okay it doesn't sound okay
to me at all bro honestly yeah it
doesn't because when you start to factor
in the relatively low prevalence of
cancer which might be one in ten your
positive predicted value and your
negative predictive value are horrible
so this is how mammography got a bad rap
and this is why some people say well you
know mammography is like yeah you should
do it but you know we don't need to do
it that often or you know you've got all
these reasons for not doing it or and
and
what I would say is yeah mammography is
really good at some types of cancer
it's good in women typically post
menopause because postmenopause their
breast tissue is much less glandular so
it's easier for the X-ray to see
it's also better when cancers have some
degree of calcification in them
but
it's not good for glandular glandular
breast tissue it's not Crea if great if
the cancer doesn't have any
calcification in it
so instead of just thinking about
mammography we should be thinking about
how do you combine mammography with
either ultrasound or MRI which are far
more sensitive now again A lot of people
are just going to say who's going to pay
for that well I'd argue that's where we
should be spending money we shouldn't be
spending money on drugs that we're going
to put people on when they have
metastatic cancer for cycle after cycle
after cycle after cycle it's much better
to spend the money right now when you
treat something that's very small
similarly for prostate cancer I mean the
PSA test has basically become persona
non grata so basically the the thinking
today is there is no official
recommendation on prostate cancer
screening despite the fact that it's the
second leading cause of cancer death in
men there is no actual recommendation on
screening
and the reason is people say the PSA
test is neither sensitive nor specific
enough and that's true it's and in
particular around the specificity it has
very low specificity
but that's if you take it in isolation
in other words if you say look we're
only going to care we're only going to
trigger you know an awareness if a guy's
PSA is over four
and if you do that you're going to be
doing a lot of unnecessary biopsies
you're also going to miss quite a few
prostate cancers
and I just think of that as like I don't
know paint by numbers right like yeah
paint by numbers sucks like if you want
to be a real artist you can't have lines
that you color in with numbers like you
have to go beyond that and to do that
for example you should be looking at the
velocity of PSA so not just looking at
so if you check a guy's PSA every year
you should be not just looking at the
number but what's the rate of change if
that is over 0.45 per year that's even
if the absolute numbers are low that's a
reason to be concerned secondly you
should be looking at PSA density so not
just looking at the PSA but dividing the
PSA by the size of the prostate so
you're looking at how much PSA is coming
out per unit size of prostate and the
bigger that number the higher the
concern
and if you have any man that's high risk
and there are lots of different things
that easily would tell you somebody's
high risk you should be doing other
tests such as a 4K test and if any of
those other things trigger you would do
a prostate MRI and if you do all of
these things you could say oh well gosh
the cost is a little bit higher yeah but
it's a fraction of the cost and the
morbidity that comes with missing that
and waiting until that cancer has spread
to the Bone because against one once
prostate cancer is spread to the bones
it there's no going back there is no
effective treatment it's a terminal
condition
so all of these things come down to just
understanding the basics of the
following observation which is
every Cancer that gets treated at an
early stage when compared to the same
cancer being traded at a late stage even
when they use the exact same drugs has a
dramatically different survival profile
and we don't need very very fancy drugs
to treat these early stage cancers
so do does the the hospitals just run
the numbers and think well we got a
hundred patients if we give them all all
this screening that's going to cost more
than what it's going to cost to give
it's not the hospitals it's the payer so
um you know it's it's a really
complicated system our system is and um
you know it's funny we were talking
about this before the podcast started
that I'll never write another book again
and that's largely true because there's
only two conditions on which I would
ever write a book again one is I'd have
to have enough time to do it and that's
not going to happen for like a decade
and two there would have to be a topic
I'd be willing to go deep enough into to
spend five years doing it one of the few
topics that would at least trigger that
is this topic right which is
and I don't know if I could ever do it
right like I just I don't know if I
could in just five years wrap my head
around this if I totally immersed myself
but how would you structurally fix our
system and
um one element of that problem is the
you have the wrong people owning the
risk right like we should actually own
the risk for our lives we would make
better decisions you want someone with
skin in the game owning the risk
hospitals should not be profiting off
disease care
like there's all these things that are
totally broken but it's it's it's the
payer that's making the calculation
that's saying
look I mean we you know we don't want to
do these things because it pays
primarily the insurance companies
or the employer so it depends on the
size so with it usually for a company
more than 50 people the employer is the
insurance company so you know if you're
if you're you know if you're General
Motors you are insuring your employees
you do it through someone that's like
looks like an insurance company you do
it through Etna or Blue Cross or
whatever but but you're the one that's
footing the bill and you're the one
that's you're the actuary basically so
but they're doing what I said which is
they got a hundred people or whatever
that number is and they run the numbers
and say look it'll cost this much money
for all this different screening or
we just roll the dice and usually the
dice come up that we'll lose a couple
people or they just look at lousy
studies right like there was a study
that got so much attention last year by
all of The anti-screening Advocates and
it was a study done in the New England
Journal of Medicine so again very
prestigious Journal it might have been
Jama but I think it was in England
Journal medicine and it was a study done
in Europe and it was testing the
hypothesis which is hey what's the
efficacy of colonoscopy for colon cancer
screening now
I mean I don't know how many pages in
this book I devote to the reasons why
colonoscopy is one of the most important
tool we have because of those five top
cancers that kill
colon cancer is the only one that we
could completely prevent meaning it's
the only one that we can definitively
look at and stop in its tracks yeah you
say that so every every colon cancer
starts as a polyp that's right and you
can see the polyps and you can get rid
of them that's right this is like just
the facts yep so here's this opportunity
this is a this is a cancer you could
basically eliminate that's right you
could eliminate that I can't say that
for breast completely or prostate or
lung or pancreatic those are more
complicated cancers obviously not
smoking would get rid of 85 percent of
lung cancer so you know that's a given
but 15 percent of lung cancers are
coming in non-smokers and if you took
all the smokers out of lung cancer and
just looked at the non-smokers and never
smokers lung cancer would still be the
seventh leading cause of cancer death
that's how devastating it is
so back to this question so so this
study
um and I believe it was done in the
Scandinavian country but I'm blanking on
exactly which one if if in fact it was
in Scandinavia it was a 10-year study
that if you read the headline you would
come away thinking yeah it's not worth
doing colonoscopy
because the headline was in the group
that was randomized to get a colonoscopy
versus the group that was randomized not
to the reduction in colon cancer was
only
oh I'm gonna sort of it's it I've
written about this briefly but I'm going
to butcher it it was small it was like a
couple of percent
and so the argument put forth by The
anti-screening Advocate would be
all those colonoscopies the cost of
doing those wasn't worth saving a couple
of percent of people from getting colon
cancer
but again here's where you have to be a
good consumer of science you cannot just
rely on the headline you have to look
finer okay so the first thing is the
study was very poorly done
the study tested
taking a group of people and telling
them to do nothing and telling a group
of people and recommending they get a
colonoscopy in the next 10 years
now I don't remember the number but it
was less than 40 percent of the people
who were told to get a colonoscopy
actually did get one colonoscopy in that
10-year window of time
so to me a more interesting study if
you're really trying so in other words
all that study told us that if you tell
people to get a colonoscopy in 10 years
and it might have been less it might
have been like it might have been 25 of
the people actually did it one in ten
years yeah you're not going to make that
much of a difference because because in
the book you say it should be it's not
once every 10 years and this this thing
can progress what do you recommend in
the book every two three years there's
no definitive answer to this because no
one can do the full math on how long it
truly takes for a polyp to develop but
in our practice we're typically looking
about every three years for modest risk
normal risk individuals higher risk
individuals so someone who gets a
colonoscopy and you find a Cecil polyp
which is a higher risk polyp or someone
who gets colonoscopy and they didn't
have a complete bowel prep so you the
endoscopist couldn't visualize the
complete colon we're going to repeat
that in a year
um but let's just say all things go well
all systems are go you go and have a
colonoscopy they pull off a couple of
pedunculated polyps that turn out to be
nothing yeah we'd recommend two to three
year repeat as aggressive as that sounds
but again in this experiment they did 10
years recommend you get it and then they
actually use this as a reason to not get
colonoscopies that's insane
how does it how does somebody publish
something like that
well again you know it's people would
look at that and say I mean it was a big
randomized controlled trial but again
there's a big confusion I mean I think
even in the medical establishment
there's a very big confusion between
what is efficacy which tests how well
something works if done perfectly versus
Effectiveness how well something works
based on how you're told to do it both
of those things are important they're
not the same
you have to know which one you're
testing
okay
so there's cancer damn
uh and I'm thinking as I as I am going
through this and as we're doing this
podcast I realized like I would I would
have been much better off to have laid
out kind of the way you lay the book out
and
I didn't do that so I apologize because
you hit these topics you know and the
next one that you get to is Alzheimer's
you say this Alzheimer's disease is
perhaps the most difficult most attract
intractable of the horsemen diseases and
you talk that's what that's another main
theme of the book tell us the horsemen
disease is the four horsemen yeah these
are the the main four diseases that that
are the result of chronic death the
chronic diseases so cardiovascular
disease cancer neurodegenerative disease
and dementia and then the fourth one is
kind of the foundational one which is
all of those metabolic diseases like
non-alcoid fatty liver disease and type
2 diabetes yep so you hit these and at
this point in the book you're talking
about the the most intractable of the
horsemen diseases we have a much more
limited understanding of how and why it
begins and how to slow or prevent it
than we do
atherosclerosis how do I say that
freaking word atherosclerosis yeah that
unlike with cancer
we currently have no way to treat it
once symptoms begin and unlike type 2
diabetes and metabolic dysfunction it
does not appear to be readily reversible
although the jury is still out on that
this is why
almost without exception my patients
fear dementia more than any other
consequence of Aging including death
they would rather die from cancer or
heart disease than lose their minds
their very selves
I had I watched a close friend of mine
actually a couple close friends of mine
their father
um got Alzheimer's and it was way more
rapid
than I envisioned
and he was a very active very physically
healthy individual
and this came on
very quickly
and it was horrible
he was angry he was confused he was
violent
uh
this is horrifying
and and another important lesson that
was passed on to all I passed this on to
everyone is they didn't try and get him
into a home
until he was
too far gone mentally where it could not
be explained to him what was happening
he didn't accept it
you know you can go and if you can make
that transition while you're more
mentally aware of what's going on and
you make the decision and now you are in
a home
but like good family is trying to do you
know we don't want to take you we don't
put you in there you know you stay out
here and he didn't want to go in right
and by the time they got him in he got
kicked out
got kicked out of the home like he was
too too violent um it was all it was
absolutely awful the only blessing in
all this is that he did die he he died
relatively quickly after it got really
bad
um
the the weird thing about this is
like you you say we we lose our minds in
their very selves
who are we
like who are you who am I what makes me
me and if I behave a certain way what am
I not me anymore
yeah it's an interesting question and
again it's a human question right it's
um I don't I don't think we can I don't
think we can think about this through
the lens of any other animal
um
you know uh
a meditator would say we are not our
thoughts right I mean I think that that
would be that would be one of the tenets
of of mindfulness-based meditation is
learning to create distance between our
thoughts
um
but you know on some level we are right
I mean I think on some level we are
um we are
we are our Consciousness we are our
thoughts
um
I think those two I don't I don't think
those two are mutually exclusive I guess
is what I'm saying I think we I think we
can I think it's very valuable to be
detached from our thoughts and it's very
important to understand that they are
things that pass through our minds and
that that that but but at the same time
you know
there are certain things about me that
would cease to make me me if they didn't
exist
I had a woman on this podcast a friend
of mine her name is Sarah Wilkinson her
husband was a seal
um Elite seal
great reputation and she they got
married when you know when he I think
they got married actually before he was
in Seal training and then she spent
spent her his career with him
and he he killed himself while he was on
active duty
um and
what she said was the guy she married
was not the guy that killed himself like
he was a different person and look what
was it it was PTSD it was explosive
breaching like all those things that the
brain gets exposed to
and that's why I've been I've been
thinking a lot about that idea lately is
you know what makes you you and at what
point are you not you anymore and I
guess there's a lot of
second and third or effects that go into
that you know do you say hey if I no
longer remember these things and I'm not
me anymore then put me in a home let me
you know put me on put me out out to
pasture
the uh
the Alzheimer's disease the way it's
described in the book when it's like uh
it sounds like spider webs kind of in
the brain is that what it is that's what
it appears to be
yeah I mean it's it's the word Dental
you like dip that's the word you use
there's a word Dental to describe what
the brain looks like well there's um I
was thinking of floss that's the only
thing you know there are these proteins
that get folded
um and and amyloid is this is the
Protein that's most associated with uh
with Alzheimer's disease and if if this
amyloid protein gets misfolded uh inside
the inside the neurons it's uh it's an
inflammatory process and then you get
these other types of neuro uh fibrillary
Tangles uh called Tau and they're kind
of these structural Tangles around the
neurons so so there's very much a
physical process that's actually
happening in the cells that are
destroying the cells and
um one of the challenges is that we
don't have a direct way to measure those
um in an early stage now as of right now
we do have some pretty interesting
advances where there are certain blood
tests that can look for things that
correlate very well with those findings
both the amyloid and the Tau
so we are just now starting to do this
type of stuff where we can use a blood
test or if you're willing to be a little
bit more aggressive you could use a
lumbar puncture so do a spinal tap on
somebody and look at the cerebral spinal
fluid we don't do that in clinical
practice but they do that in research
studies
and you can identify beta amyloid and
Tau in people who are still normal
um
and we can use that and you might say
well what's the value in that I think
can you do anything with that yeah I
think the value in that is we can we can
start to reverse that and we are seeing
that uh now again this is still too
early to tell because it hasn't been you
know studied in a large rigorous fashion
so anecdotally all I can tell you is we
do see that making positive changes and
there's you know we can list what those
changes are can take people who are
pre-clinical so either they don't have
any signs of cognitive impairment or
they only have mild signs called MCI of
cognitive impairment and we can pull
those people back what I don't think we
can do is take people in Frank dementia
and make a difference
well speaking of what we can do about
these things and and I'll I'll give
myself a little reprieve here in saying
that this next part of the book that you
write part three of the book is the
basically what we can do about it part
of the book
and uh you go through a section talking
about thinking tactically versus
thinking strategically which is a great
thing to put in a book especially for my
military perspective strategically
obviously the big picture of what we're
trying to accomplish overall in
tactically how do we actually make these
things happen
and you say this in medicine 3.0 which I
think we've described now and I
apologize for not describing that more
clearly out of the gate this is this is
us trying to prevent things from
happening medicine 3.0 we have five
tactical domains that we can address in
order to alter someone's Health the
first is exercise
which I consider to be the far most
potent dominant in sorry potent domain
in terms of its impact on both lifespan
and health span of course exercise is
not just one thing so I break it down
into components of aerobic efficiency
maximum aerobic output VO2 max strength
and stability all of which we'll discuss
in more detail next is diet or nutrition
or as I prefer to call it nutritional
biochemistry
the third domain is sleep which has gone
unappreciated by medicine 2.0 until
relatively recently the fourth domain
encompasses a set of tools and
techniques to manage and improve
emotional health our fifth and final
domain consists of various drugs
supplements and hormones that doctors
learn about in medical school and Beyond
I lump these into one bucket called
exogenous molecules meaning molecules we
ingest from outside the body
and the beautiful thing about those is
we can control
all those different things we have some
level of control over
which is awesome uh chapter 11.
exercise the most powerful longevity
drug
I never want to fight in the ring I
always won in preparation Muhammad Ali
uh
this gives good background here several
years ago my friend John Griffin pinged
me with a question about how he should
be exercising should he be doing more
cardio or more weights what did I think
I'm really confused by all the
contradictory stuff I'm seeing out there
he wrote behind his seemingly simple
question I heard a plea for help John is
a smart guy with an incisive mind and
yet he was even he was frustrated by all
the conflicting advice from experts
touting this or that workout as the sure
path to perfect health he couldn't
figure out what he needed to be doing in
the gym or why this is before I had
gotten back into full-time practice of
medicine at the time I was immersed in
the world of nutrition research
which if anything is more confounding
than exercise science Rife with
contradictory findings and passionately
held dogmas backed by flimsy data are
eggs bad bad or good what about coffee
it was driving me nuts too
I remember those days
uh I started typing out a reply and kept
on writing by the time I hit send I had
written close to 2 000 words way more
than he asked for the poor guy just
wanted to click answer not a memo I
didn't stop there either I either I
later expanded that email to a 10 000
word manifesto on longevity which
eventually grew into the book you're
holding in your hands clearly something
about John's question triggered me it's
not that I was a passionate devotee of
strength or training over endurance or
vice versa I'd done plenty of both I was
reacting to the binary nature of his
question in case you haven't figured it
out by now I'm not fond of the way we
reduce these complex nuanced vitally
important questions down to simple
either ORS cardio or weights low carb or
plant-based olive oil or beef tallow I
don't know must we really make take
sides the problem and we shall see this
again in the nutrition chapters is that
we have this need to turn everything
into a kind of religious War over which
is the one true church some extra
experts insist that strength training is
superior to cardio while an equal number
assert the opposite the debate is as
endless as it is pointless sacrificing
science on the altar of advocacy
the problem is that we are looking at
these hugely important domains of life
exercise but also nutrition through far
too narrow a lens it's not about which
side of the gym you prefer it's so much
more essential than that more than any
other tactical domain we discussed in
this book exercise has the greatest
power to determine how you will live out
the rest of your life there are reams of
data supporting the notion that even a
fairly minimal amount of exercise can
lengthen your life by several years it
delays the onset of chronic diseases
pretty much across the board but it also
amazingly of is amazingly effective at
extending and improving Health span not
only does it reverse a physical decline
which I suppose is somewhat obvious but
it can slow or Reserve or reverse
cognitive decline as well so if you
adopt only one new set of habits based
on reading this book it must be in the
realm of exercise if you currently
exercise you will likely want to
rethinker and modify your program and if
exercise is not part of your life at the
moment you are not alone 70 percent of
the U.S population is like you
now is the time to change that right now
even a little bit of daily activity is
much better than nothing going from zero
weekly exercise to just 90 minutes per
week can reduce your risk from dying
from all causes by 14 it's very hard to
find a drug that can do that thus my
answer to questions like the one my
friend John Griffin asked me is yes and
yes yes you should be doing more cardio
and yes you should be lifting more
weights
yes
I was so stoked when I was reading this
part of a book because I finally felt
like I was doing something good because
I work out very religiously and uh that
that was awesome so I should have had
you read that chapter oh what do you
think yeah yeah like don't you think a
guest reading how did we not think of
that that would have been cool yeah that
would have been cool guest reading by
Jocko yeah I could have thrown in this
little chapter here
um I would have to get somebody to help
me you know put the phonetic
pronunciation for some of the words
uh what I was thinking so so that was
weird 77 of people that don't exercise I
am so if you were to ask me that
question I would have said it was
probably going to be at least 15 or 20
percent of people in America that don't
exercise like that's how that's how much
I mean obviously I own a gym
I do jiu-jitsu
I do CrossFit like everything that I'm
doing I'm around people that work out
and people that come up and talk to me
all over the world they all work out so
70 percent
that's crazy uh what with your patience
is there anything that stops your
patients from exercising when you get
that patient that's like
you give them the program and three
months later he's like well you know
next month I'm really gonna start for
real because he hasn't done anything yet
what's the what holds him back
yeah I think there are probably a number
of things so
there's probably a subset of people who
genuinely don't enjoy it
um
and I try to be sympathetic to that
because I acknowledge that I genuinely
do enjoy it
now what's not clear to me is do I enjoy
it because I just started it at such a
young age and it's always been a part of
my life and
I've done it enough to appreciate the
short-term and long-term benefits of it
um
you know one of the things I try to
explain to people is that
all of these things that we're talking
about but let's use exercise because I
think it's the most important
have an advantage over of them that
saving for retirement does not
so
it's not like rocket science that you
would tell somebody when they get out of
college and start their first job like
you gotta you gotta put some money away
right you got to save money for for when
you're you know gonna retire and
um
that you know there's value in that and
we understand that
um but we should also acknowledge that
when you ask somebody to do that there's
no short-term gain that comes from that
so if you're making a thousand bucks a
week and you want to set aside 150 bucks
a week
there's lots of long-term gain to that
but let's be clear you get nothing in
the short term for doing that you're
just a hundred and fifty dollars lighter
every week it's 150 bucks you could be
spending on anything and you are not
but
almost everybody would agree that
there's value in doing this
with exercise
I can point them to all the long-term
data and I I can make a more compelling
case for this than I can for anything
else again I can't restate this enough
right like
is it better to be fit than to not smoke
yes is it better to be fit than to not
be obese not have diabetes not have high
blood pressure
nothing compares to Extreme Fitness in
terms of lifespan with with respect to
all cause mortality and health span
I can give them all of that that's like
saying you can save that 150 a week
and I'm going to give you the greatest
rate of return I have an investment
vehicle that's going to give you the
greatest rate of return such that that
150 a week is going to be 10 million
dollars in 40 years that would require a
great rate of return
but
but I can say that guess what you also
get something in the short term yeah you
do like you get something every single
day that you do it
and that's why I mean by exercises this
really potent drug and we can't
replicate it because it's not just one
molecule
it's doing so much every single time you
pound it right you're getting an
endorphin raise you're getting an
immediate response to your vascular
system it's changing your energy levels
it's allowing you to do things here and
now that make you better there's a
psychological component when you do
something that is difficult in the gym
or on the track or in the pool or
wherever you choose to get your exercise
and you develop a sense of fortitude
again I'm saying any of these things to
your audience is dumb right it's sort of
like what's the expression it's like
telling singing to the choir yeah
singing to the choir saying something
about the pope right so so I don't need
to go through all of that but
but
if someone's never done it and they've
never experienced the short-term
benefits the inertia can be really hard
so so again I think this is an argument
for I think why we want kids to be
active I think it's very important that
kids are active because I think this is
a very important lifelong skill and so
again I you know I'm sure you've been
asked these questions like if you could
you know
change one thing in the in the in the in
the world today what would it be with
respect to you know your particular
issue and I think for me the one thing I
would probably change is Institute a
much more rigorous process of fiscal
education and exercise
um from from basically the time kids are
born so it's just take all those
movements that kids do perfectly which
they do they're all perfect when they're
born and just never let that go away and
everything should be built around
movement everything education should be
built around movement isn't that crazy
gone in complete opposite direction like
they don't they have schools with no PE
now and and when they do have PE it's
like nothing uh no it's funny you're
saying this stuff I don't need to tell
your audiences but you actually when I
wrote discipline equals freedom field
manual I sent you speaking of chapters I
sent you the chapter on physical fitness
and I was like hey I got and on diet I
was like hey man here's what I'm here's
what I'm putting out how am I doing and
you're like freaking good to go because
which meant I basically had already been
listening to you for a while so so uh
that's cool but
oh I wasn't gonna say oh I was gonna say
this I this reminded me you talk about
like putting money in the bank
physically I remember when I was gonna
join the Navy and I was like damn you
know this is like 20 years a long time
but I remember thinking to me as a 17
year old hey when I when I joined I'm
gonna be in such good physical shape
that when I get out I'll still be like
good to go and I was right like it
teaches you a lot about physical fitness
and it becomes a physical culture of
life is there anything so if you get one
of these clients of yours one of your
patients
by the way you have a practice where you
help people with longevity again I'm
skipping all kinds of stuff today uh
when you have someone that doesn't want
to exercise have you found anything that
helps them and I have to preemptively
say this
people ask me all the time like well how
does someone get through SEAL training
and some people say like you know you uh
you've got to have something like really
meaningful the fact of the matter is
there's guys that like have an a
girlfriend that dumped them in high
school I'm gonna show her I'm gonna be a
seal and they make it there's someone
else that you know told his dad that I'm
gonna do this and that's enough there's
like it and there's someone else that's
like oh they told me I couldn't do it at
the recruiting station so I'm gonna do
it just to prove them wrong there's and
there's some people like oh I want to
serve my country I want these people
have an infinite number of reasons that
they just make it through this program
and it doesn't really matter it doesn't
really matter which one you have some
people you'll I I see people on like uh
online will comment like you'll never
make it through if you don't have the
why or if you and I'm like bro you don't
know this dude just like wants to prove
his older brother wrong and he makes it
like that stuff happens
have you figured out a way to coerce
that out of people so they understand
the value that they'll get if they
freaking exercise 90 minutes a week
yeah it's a combination of things and
it's different for everybody but I
definitely do a little bit of carrot and
a little bit of stick so the stick is
usually showing them what the end looks
like without it It's Going Straight
Scared Straight well it's it's marginal
decade reality right it's like okay so
let's let's talk about the inevitability
of decline well I don't know what you
told Leif Babin but I called him today
and he was like he's like breathing hard
and I'm like oh what's going on he's
like you know finish up a workout I was
like oh I'm getting ready to record with
Peter attia right now and he goes yeah
that's why I'm here right now we're
talking about that marginal decade man
I'm I got my I'm not on the path right
now which is funny you know I've been
he's been hanging out with me for
freaking 17 years but it wasn't until he
looked at his marginal decade from you
where he's like I better get my ass in
the gym so there you go good job yeah
and look part of it is we're all victims
of what works for us and for me that's a
very motivating thing like it's really
motivating for me to think about that
last decade I'm now old enough that some
of the things that used to motivate me
don't vanity motivates me less okay I'm
gonna be honest like the first time I
step a foot in the gym it was
for a totally different set of reasons
than the reason I lift weights today
you wanted them guns yeah you didn't you
didn't want it you didn't want to be you
didn't want to be the scrawny kid
anymore right you wanted to show
everybody how strong you were how tough
you were and that and and sort of none
of that stuff means to me today what it
did then so now I I have a different
point of view but but I will say this
look that's the stick part the carrot
part is uh and this is this has come
with with you know more years doing this
is realizing that I just want someone to
get a win because once they get a win
they're going to get addicted to the win
so when I start with that patient who's
doing nothing
I don't I hate when they say Peter what
do you do because I'm like wrong
question like for me to tell you what I
do is just going to make you feel worse
and make you feel like this is not you
know achievable it's not achievable so
let's forget that who cares what I do
I've been doing this since I was a fetus
basically what what do we want you to do
and I will say something like hey if we
can get you working out three hours a
week
well actually I take a step back and I
go how many hours are you willing to
give me of your time
and they might say 90 minutes and they
might say three hours and they might say
five hours whatever it is but let's just
say they say three hours I say great and
I point them to the date and I say look
with a three hour
if you gave me three hours of your time
and I could do whatever I wanted with
you during that period of time and I
promise we're not going to hurt you
right we're gonna we're gonna take this
incrementally you know this is how much
we're going to
extend your life potentially and we're
talking about years and this is the
difference in quality of life so I get
them to buy into that okay then I say
all right here's the formula
half of that time we're going to do
cardio half of that time we're going to
do strength training and what does the
cardio look like I show them what it's
going to look like and it's not crushing
we're just not there to crush anybody
they don't have any aerobic base at this
point so all I want them doing is really
easy peasy stuff and it's just about
habit building as much as it is about
the stuff and it's like hey like this is
a great time for you to listen to
podcasts listen to audiobooks listen to
music whatever it is in the weight room
we're not I don't care what you do if
you're someone who wants to go to a gym
and work out on a bunch of machines
because they don't look intimidating
that's great
but if you want to do something a little
more complicated let's just get you
carrying things can you you know and
again it's a bit more nuanced because I
want to make sure they can do it safely
and all these other things but it's like
what a step UPS on a box look like what
does carrying look like so they might
have this idea that they're walking into
a CrossFit gym and they're going to be
doing cleans and they're going to be
squatting and deadlifting it's like no
no you're not gonna be doing any of that
stuff anytime soon
um and and and I think if people give
you three to six months of that
I'm still waiting for someone who at the
end of that period of time says I don't
feel better
and if they as long as as long as you
get there your your home run then you're
good yeah
uh the chapter goes I mean the chapters
all kinds of good detail in there zone
two VO2 max strength training grip
strength concentric and eccentric
loading and you cover all kinds of stuff
in there with in in clear language that
helps people understand what they need
to do so go get the book
the next section here is
the gospel of stability
chapter 13.
re-learning how to move to prevent
injury this is like a journey that you
had to go on and what does it mean to
you when you when you want to explain to
people what is what do you mean by the
gospel of stability
you know I mean this is a I think it's
one of the most complicated chapters in
the book and it was definitely the
hardest one to write from a technical
standpoint because
I think stability is something people
kind of understand but it doesn't really
have a great definition I mean I Define
it in there in the the you know the best
ways I can but I think the easiest way
to think about it is
you know a stable body is a body that
transmits Force to the outside world
without dissipation of force and energy
leak and it's one to which force can be
applied without
internal collapse and dissipation of
energy or injury so
um you know just an example thinking
about that right like you know if if
you're walking up a flight of stairs and
or you're carrying something heavy up a
hill and your knees hurt or you're
walking down a hill and your knees hurt
that's that's an energy dissipation
right and and you can you can really go
through what's the path of force from
the point of contact which virtually
every time we're making contact with the
outside world it's our hands and our
feet that are doing the contact and how
is that force moving from your hand or
from your feet into the center of your
body because that's that's where it's
always going right so you're you know
your feet are transmitting Force through
your ankles your knees your hips into
your pelvis Etc
and you know stability really comes down
to
you know creating an exoskeleton
um that allows that force to be
transmitted safely so the injuries that
we have many of which are chronic but
even the acute ones are usually acute on
chronic weaknesses so you know when
somebody
tears their ACL
that wouldn't necessarily have happened
you know if you took 10 people and
exposed them to that same Force at that
same moment maybe seven of them would
have torn their ACL three of them
wouldn't have
um and and a lot of that can be
attributed to different types of
strength so stability in the knee for
example lateral strength in the knee
um stability within the back explains a
lot of why people have you know as I did
lower back injuries and why
um you know failure to generate
sufficient intra-abdominal pressure can
lead to energy leak so
to me this concept of stability goes so
hand in hand with strength because
a big part of Health span is not just
being strong and having you know good
cardio respiratory Fitness it's also
being free of injury it's being
relatively pain-free
um and I think that a very important
part of this journey for me personally
has been learning how to manage the sins
of my youth from an injury perspective
I I I often get asked about like you
know this kind of stuff especially with
Jiu Jitsu people they're like oh you
know you what what injuries have you had
and I'm like um
I'm pretty good to go
you know I'm pretty good to go and I
think the reason that I'm pretty good to
go again knock on wood a thousand times
is because I I work out and I work out
religiously so I think that
when you you know you put your foot down
you put your arm down and you get
injured because that's what happens we
have a friend that just towards ACL like
just taking a step literally like he's
doing Jiu Jitsu but he wasn't getting
heel hooked he wasn't no nothing Dynamic
he was taking a step he's actually
taking a step backwards felt a tweak
falls down on the mat
like holding his knee
torn ACL from nothing
scary but I feel like working out
lifting squatting doing pull-ups doing
dips I feel like those things
I feel like I feel like I have pretty
good stability I I at this juncture I
need to work on my flexibility again I I
worked on my flexibility several years
ago
and I got flexible and I felt good about
it and then I I'm the worst I'm the
worst which like give me an example of
something that is is sub-optimal for you
my shoulders are really really
inflexible right now they're really
inflexible night and I've lost a lot of
mobility in them and I've just started
getting it back started proactively
doing the stretches that I did for I
just I just shoulder that hurt me one
time this was
probably 15 years ago maybe even longer
than that yeah it's probably 15 or 20
years ago I had a shoulder that was
constantly hurting constantly hurting
constantly hurting and finally I
did like religious stretching and the
pain went away and the mobility
increased and it felt great so I'm gonna
go through that protocol again and get
it back but those are the kind of things
where
I know and another thing you know I had
to uh you know burst siren from sorenex
no anyways I had was oh builds gyms
built my gym but we were having a
conversation and
it's really easy to have an exercise
that you for whatever reason
can't do for whatever period of time for
instance a pull-up right you could say
oh I hurt my shoulder can't do a pull-up
it's very easy
to never do a pull-up again in your life
and that's not good so what I told him
is like I don't even whatever I try and
keep the exercises that I've been able
to do before
and continually try and maintain them
and if for some reason like I I got a I
got an arm injury by Dean Lister my
friend my coach he's showing a jiu jitsu
move
he's never hurt me while we're training
in 20 something years he was showing a
move and like really hurt my arm and so
for
six or seven months I couldn't do an
overhead squat because I just could not
ex you know you gotta kind of lock out
your arms under overhead score I could
not do it and when I finally could
extend my arms again
I could I just didn't have the strength
anymore and I could see I was like oh
that's what happens to people what
happens to people is they go oh I guess
that's gone
and I said to myself I will not submit
to this I will give me the PVC pipe
where let's start again let's go and
slowly started building that strength
back so I think that's what happens and
I know we've got a section in here about
or maybe we already covered the section
but you talk about the fact that you you
see people get derailed matter of fact
one one of the stories you telling here
is one of your friends moms
she was healthy doing well she fell
broke hip FEMA or something and then all
sudden you can't work in the garden you
can't walk around anymore and everything
falls apart
that's why here's you want great here's
some great piece of advice I don't know
if you have this in here this is from me
because I get asked this question all
the time
I hurt my arm I hurt my back I hurt my
whatever I'm sick what should I do and
this is such a good answer I'm going to
give it to you do what you can
you do what you can you look you used to
be able to do 20 pull-ups and now you
can only do a negative and only on one
arm right now because your shoulders
hurt and your other arm cool do what you
can
oh you can't run anymore because you got
your knees tweaked cool but you can go
on the hand bike cool do what you can
and then try and get back try and
try and aggressively go back not too
aggressively but go back and and retake
those exercises retail I was I was uh
building a house and while I was
building a house I was living in another
house
my house that I was living in had a
garage where I put my garage gym with
whatever seven foot ceilings I couldn't
do muscle ups in those and I didn't
think much about it it wasn't like I was
injured or anything I just oh you know
and it took 18 months to build the house
so for 18 months I would wasn't really
doing muscle ups didn't really think
about it again you know you just
couldn't couldn't go up that high so it
just wasn't doing didn't think about it
I was really excited I got back to my
new house
had my I have
I have 20 foot ceilings in my garage now
so like I can do Muslims rope climbs
everything but I did that first muscle
up workout and I was like oh
oh
you got weak in this pajama look I did
dips the whole time I did pulse all time
but I got weak and then I just had to
rebuild that that's a good thing is if
you've had to rebuild before from an
injury
you realize that you can rebuild you had
the shoulder surgery yeah so I had um I
tore my labrum
probably for the first time in boxing
anytime you once you dislocate or sublux
your shoulder you're gonna damage that
labrum and so I had multiple
subluxations in my in my teenage years
and then swimming you know as an extreme
distance swimmer that that sort of made
things worse so by about
2012. it was it was sufficiently bad
that I knew surgery you know I knew I
was going to need surgery but I met you
know some really good folks who rehabbed
me to the point where I was doing
awesome so in 2020 when we came to
Austin
um I you know met this awesome well
actually I'd met him many years before
but he happened to be in Austin he was
an orthopedic surgeon that split his
time between New York and Austin named
Alton Baron and I went to see Alton
having a little shoulder pain
and he said well let's do another MRI
it's been you know eight years since
your last one and it's like yeah it's
horrible like dude you're you don't have
a labrum it's just it's all hanging off
there and more importantly that explains
your symptoms right the MRI by itself
doesn't actually tell you the whole
story it's let me examine you and see
where your pain is and um he's like yeah
I mean luckily you do so much other
stuff like your rotator cuff is in
amazing shape it's so strong but your
rotator cuff is stabilizing your
shoulder
um and not your labor your labrum is
what should be holding that in place
so I said so do I do you think I need
surgery now he goes no I wouldn't I
wouldn't do it until you can't take it
anymore like let's see how far you can
milk this and I was like great and then
finally in one day in 2022 January 2022
I was I was uh driving my car at the
racetrack and there was just something
about the way I was getting in and out
of the car that day that just finally
tipped it over the edge and to make a
long story short we were like yep okay
now it's time to do the surgery so we
did the surgery in March of 22.
and I actually put a video up on
Instagram of him examining me under
anesthesia on the table because that's
the only time he could ever fully
demonstrate how loose the shoulder was
because I had to be under general
anesthesia for the rotator cuff to relax
and it's one of the most gruesome videos
you'll ever see it's like I'm sitting up
intubated oh I remember this yeah yeah
yeah yeah and he's just gone and I mean
it's like he demonstrates like if there
was any doubt that you needed this
surgery we just erased that doubt so I
have the surgery and
um it's so funny to hear you talk about
you know what you just said because
these are all my fears right it's like
you know grip strength is such an
important part of my existence like so
much of what I do is predicated on being
able to carry things being able to hang
being able to do pull-ups you know the
dead hang is one of my favorite tests
it's a it's not a regular part of my
training but it's a test set twice a
month I will do a dead hang for time and
there's something we do with our
patients
and you know my goal was to get to five
minutes you know five minutes is
generally considered the gold standard
like if you can dead hang for five
minutes you're you're really special I'd
never got there but I was at like four
four minutes and 36 seconds or something
how big of a bar
um probably like a oh oh you know I do
it on a 45 like a regular like okay yeah
um so I put that up on the pull-up bar
can it rotate while it's there
it doesn't okay yeah it's it's sort of
locked in cool cool
um
my wife by the way first time she ever
did a dead hang went 308. damn like
that's ridiculous for anybody but for a
woman that's really strong
um so
I knew that post-surgery like it was
going to be and again not this is not
true for every shoulder surgery but
because of the because of the nature of
mine I knew it was going to be six
months before I could deadlift
and it was gonna be six months before I
could carry anything very heavy
so I knew how much my grip strength was
going to decline so I did as much as I
could around it right so it's funny the
day after surgery I was in the gym in a
sling doing leg extensions and leg curls
and within three days I was even able to
do this other machine where you strap a
belt to your waist and you do like you
know sort of like deadlifts but without
holding the bar so it's
um
but I'll tell you what here we are today
15 months post surgery I still can't get
the four and a half minutes like and I'm
working at it but that's like I tell
this story to say
when you lose it it can take a while to
get it back
and why this matters is
the most important rule of working out
is don't injure yourself doing it
because once you get to a certain age
anytime on the sidelines is going to
just
make it harder and harder to get back so
you know you alluded to the broken hip
story right I mean these statistics are
so important to understand for two
reasons one is so let's just State the
stats once you're 65 and up
if you fall and break your hip or femur
depending on the study there's a 15 to
30 percent chance you're dead in a year
the one-year mortality of a broken hip
or Femur for those age 65 and up is 15
to 30 percent
what's equally tragic in my mind is of
the 70 to 85 percent of people who don't
actually die
half of them will have a full level
reduction in Mobility meaning if they
were able to walk easily before they
will require a cane
for the rest of their lives if they were
walking with a cane before they will go
to a walker if they were in a walker
before they will go to a wheelchair
that's called a full reduction in
functionality what if someone's a
freaking stud and there's 72 years old
and they break their femur doing jiu
jitsu
they're more likely to survive than
someone who's not right because I mean
again there's a lot of acute things that
can go wrong you know you can have a fat
embolism you can have a you know a
pulmonary embolism there's a lot of
stuff that can go wrong in the
perioperative phase but a big part of
why those people die
if they don't die immediately it's the
inactivity it's you know once you
reach a certain age
it can take
six months to 12 months to put on the
amount of muscle you'd lose from 10 days
of inactivity
think about that for a second right like
10 days of inactivity
is not a lot for someone who gets
injured if that's like you oh you went
on vacation and decided oh you know what
I'm just gonna relax and you didn't work
out well it's funny you say that I mean
this is one of the things we talk about
a lot with our patients is we've got a
lot of patients and at the end of the
year they're not making gains and what
we're realizing is
you know you're in Ibiza for a month
like you undid all the work you did now
again you're not killing it for those 11
months but you're doing good enough for
11 months but you just undid it in a
month what is that what is that when
you're 23.
um I don't know but it wouldn't be as
dramatic it seemed like when I was 23
goodness nothing matter yeah it was just
it was just like nothing mattered just
do whatever you're still it's gonna
Crush yeah yeah but but you know the
experiments that are done are done in
you know 60 65 year olds and as you get
older you become more anabolically
resistant
that meaning literally it is harder to
experience anabolic function you require
more protein to make the same amount of
muscle
um you good more steak let's go
so you can continue how much denial
there is over here on my side of the
table like I'm like hey the guy I was
talking about earlier that won't happen
to me that's me all day long
that's my attitude it's freaking jacked
up or it's really cool I don't know what
do you think Carrie I think it's good to
go more steak more milk more Jujitsu
just keep it rolling now
uh so you again the chapter and go ahead
oh no I was gonna ask you tell me tell
me a little bit about um I mean Jiu
Jitsu fascinates me I don't do it I've
never done it my boys both do it they
love it I'm so happy to see them doing
it
um it seems especially the younger ones
still you know you just have a hard time
getting his attention sometimes but
um but the older one who's eight like it
really is the thing he loves
um I can really see him doing this uh as
as his thing he loves it in a way that
he didn't love any other thing he tried
yes
um
and so you know like do kids get injured
doing this I mean like what are the what
are the what are the things that a
parent needs to understand as their kid
is doing Jiu Jitsu kid's gonna get
internet Jiu Jitsu same likelihood
soccer basketball uh whatever else what
are the main injuries are they head
injuries are they shoulder injuries knee
injuries
knees shoulders
elbows just sort of like they're playing
basketball
um so it's more resilient because it
just freak bounce back so much quicker
kids
honestly my kids didn't get hurt during
Jiu Jitsu like they were doing Jiu Jitsu
seven days a week from the ages of zero
no from the ages of five to like for the
girls five to twelve and for my son
five until current time and
they never had any kind of serious
injury my daughter that did gymnastics
got injuries from gymnastics my daughter
that did ballet got way worse injuries
ballet is crazy
um so I don't think there's like huge
for kids I think it's great and what
about the opposite end of the spectrum
like what are the oldest people you have
coming into the gym 60 yep but no one in
their 70s and 80s
there's people that there's people that
compete at 70 they have a master's
division at 70 and up uh it's definitely
you know depends on the person
um
you can do it I mean Elio Gracie the the
founder of Gracie Jiu Jitsu he was doing
Jiu Jitsu and rolling until you know he
was in his 80s 90s still doing it so you
can do it I think it can be a lifelong
sport I think it'd be a lifelong sport
as much as as much as
tennis or golf or
you know people play pick up basketball
I mean it just depends on what you do
with yourself and if you let those
little movements slip away and you don't
say to yourself hey I'm gonna get that
movement back
you know if you don't do that
it's going to go if you don't if you
don't use it you're gonna lose it that's
that's an accurate statement so I the
other thing that's great about Jiu Jitsu
is you know they're going to get
cardiovascular work they're going to get
strength training they're gonna get
flexibility all from one big thing so
that's kind of nice too not to mention
they'll never get they'll never get beat
up
at least not in school by someone their
own age right can there be a 16 year old
when they're 12 yeah but generally
speaking 16 year olds don't beat up 12
year olds like generally speaking
they might bully them they might push
them around but you usually have peer or
near peer bullying situations
and so so they're not going to get
bullied which is amazing they're going
to be able to protect other people and
what's interesting they generally
speaking will not become bullies because
they understand what physical
confrontation does to people and they
don't like it and they recognize that
it's not a way to get power over people
so it's beneficial across the board
across the board freaking awesome
do you have an occasional like
catastrophic
injury in Jiu Jitsu yep
competition yup with kids competition
they generally hopefully have
referees that will stop the match if you
know a kid gets in an arm lock and he's
not tapping because little kids they
won't tap they want to win so bad they
won't tap and so a good ref will stop
the match you win you know the other kid
wins sorry you you shouldn't have gotten
caught in that position I always coached
and refer like that hey I don't care if
you weren't going to tap you were caught
in that position you lose
but but they also are pretty safe the
way they do it in terms of they don't
allow certain submission holds at
certain ages because you don't have the
maturity to tap out
there's moves in Jiu Jitsu there's a
move called the heel hook which is
putting torsion on the ankle but what it
ends up doing is it's very strange it's
very different than other submission
holds because it doesn't hurt
until it
until it injures you so you can see a
lot of people they don't want to tap
they don't want to tap they don't want
to tap boom and you don't want to tap do
they know they're in the heel hook they
know they're in the heel hook generally
so they're just thinking I can get out
of this I can get out I can get out can
you get out of it you can yes you can
you can get out of some heel Hooks and
that's what they're trying to do and
I always we know we as instructors
instructors in general always saying Hey
listen this doesn't hurt on arm lock it
hurts before you're injured
a a a choke you just go to sleep
um a straight knee lock it hurts before
you're injured but the heel hook I mean
you tell me you're the doctor like you
don't have nerves inside your knee by
your ACL that's telling you there's
pressure there right that's just there
and what would the purpose of being
they're being nervous I don't guess
there wouldn't be any so in in the heel
hook manipulates the the knee but it's
the the pressures coming from the heel
and the foot right so with like any
straight arm lock or anything like that
the pressure is directly on the joint
that you're manipulating yeah this one's
like you know the the next one in the
chain that's actually getting the the
pressure and the Damage yeah there was
just uh my kids just sent me a video of
someone getting heel hooked and luckily
for the person that didn't tap you could
see that it broke their tip FIP it just
broke the bones which is great because
then you're fine you know you get four
weeks later it's stronger than it was
you know that acl's lifelong you're
dealing with yeah so yes Jiu Jitsu safe
and beautiful for your children the most
important thing you can give children
even more important than love
uh you got a whole chapter about that
stuff stability you go into nutrition
here
and you kick it off with you say potato
I say nutritional biochemistry
which is classic then you got a a quote
from Feynman in here religion is a
culture of Faith science is a culture of
doubt
very important to understand and you
tell a story in here I'm not going to
read it but it's the same story that I
freaking had with my wife who used to be
like you're not allowed to talk about
nutrition with my friends like and this
was in the I guess it was in the 2000s
where I was pretty fired up about
nutrition and of course my wife's
friends would would go crazy at the
table with me you know oh you're giving
your kids poison that's cool that was
how I'd open up the conversation
um and then you say this
uh
actually you say I am no longer a
dogmatic advocate of any particular way
of eating such as a ketogenic diet or
any form of fasting it took me a long
time to figure this out but the
fundamental assumption underlying the
diet Wars and most nutrition research
that there is one perfect diet that
works best for every single person is
absolutely incorrect more than anything
I owe this lesson to my patients whose
struggles have taught me a humility
about nutrition that I never could have
learned from Reading scientific papers
alone
so that's what you figured out people
are different
and again Perfection can often be the
enemy of good
um and and so we
we want to be careful that we don't
um
lose sight of what is known and what is
speculated and what's a first order term
versus a fifth order term
and I think what's abundantly clear are
the first order terms give me an example
don't be overnourished and don't be
undernourished
consume sufficient enough protein to
support the anabolic activity of muscle
uh derive sufficient micronutrients from
your food vitamins minerals things like
that
avoid toxins in food
that's about it
so good advice I I had a friend here at
this gym and he was got pretty chunky
we might go so far as to say he got fat
he was overnourished he was
overnourished and then you know six
months later he's back to his kind of
fighting weight and I said Ralph you
don't even cut some serious weight huh
I said yeah yeah I did I said would you
like what'd you do he said I stopped
eating like an [__]
and I was like everybody that's that's
probably a great diet stop eating like
an [__] because we all know what that
means
and you don't have to read a freaking
book or be a scientist to know what
eating like an [__] donut [__]
right if we could go down the list like
how much spaghetti can you possibly eat
I can eat it all
if I'm an [__] to myself
um yeah it's I found it very helpful
that you are explaining to people and
then you go you go into
you know you talk about everything in
this chapter
um and and you hit the dietary
I mean that's kind of the irony of this
I wrote two chapters on nutrition it's a
17 chapter book exercise gets three
chapters that's insane nutrition gets
two everything else gets one and
um you know there was a part of me that
wanted to do a very glib chapter on
nutrition which would have been a
paragraph basically just stating the
kind of stuff we're talking about don't
eat like an [__] yeah it's like look
be an energy ballast get enough protein
avoid the toxins get the right but but
of course I go into the detail right
which is
you have to be able to answer three
questions about yourself or anybody else
if you're in the business of trying to
treat this
and and again it's really easy to get
the answers to these three questions are
you over nourished or undernourished are
you adequately muscled or under muscled
are you metabolically healthy or not
when you know the answer to that
question
then it's just a matter of understanding
do you need to increase intake decrease
intake maintain intake go up or down on
protein
and what do you need to do with exercise
sleep and all the other things that
factor into that vis-a-vis metabolic
health
for most people the answer is you need
to eat less
you need more protein so you need less
total calories you need more protein
calories and that's what brings it full
circle to strategy versus tactics right
so there are basically three strategies
to reduce energy intake dietary
restriction calorie restriction time
restriction
so once you identify your strategy then
you can get into all the tactics and the
tactics is where the religion happens
people get crazy it's unbelievable
you were kind of crazy yeah
bro you were doing I went out to dinner
with you in New York it was like you me
Tim like just a a bunch of dudes and we
were out having a good time I still
remember the restaurant yeah I was
freaking delicious but you wouldn't know
I would not because you sat there with
an empty plate in front of you because
you were in the middle of a fortnight
five days into a seven day pass or
something yeah
oh that was awesome I that you really
missed out that night though that steak
I got was amazing I've been back since
my place you tripled down
uh so look again I I just have a note
here that says get the book because this
is a textbook this is going to help you
do an assessment it's going to help you
answer those questions and then guide
you in in a direction of which of these
strategies and tactics you can utilize
to sort your nutrition out
um the next section is the Awakening
your favorite section yeah and you know
what I figured this was gonna happen
so I broke out my book discipline equals
freedom field manual and here's what it
says
sleep is a necessity humans need sleep
failure to get enough sleep has serious
side effects lack of sleep can cause
negative hormonal changes interfere with
the metabolizing of glucose increase
blood pressure and suppress the immune
system less sleep also means less human
growth hormone in your body which means
less muscle mass and weaker bones
mentally the brain is impacted as the
ability to pay attention and concentrate
begins to diminish and problem solving
and basic reasoning become less acute
furthermore over an extended period
there are psychological effects like
paranoia and even hallucinations
so that's me you're on it you got it
that's me I wrote that
now because you know like
I don't know people think uh I wake up
early I've always waked up early
I've always woken up early and
um people think I don't believe in sleep
or that you need sleep and I'm I'm not
like that I actually understand that
people need sleep and the and quite
frankly other people need more sleep
than I do that's just the way it is I'm
not bragging it's been like that my
whole life I have I don't need a lot of
sleep and that's the way it is but I've
never told anyone like hey you need to
sleep less I've never told anybody that
let me confirm I don't think I've ever
told anybody that I've never told
anybody hey you need to sleep less
um and you go into some pretty great
detail in this book about sleep and it
actually
you know I'll just read the section old
man blood
uh scary as it can be in some situations
this short-term harm done by a knight or
three of poor sleep pales in comparison
to the damage that we do to ourselves if
this situation continues Kirk parsley
who's been on this podcast observed this
when he was a physician to the seals he
was also a seal
outwardly these men appeared to be prime
physical specimens finally honed in the
rigorous training but when parsley
analyzed their blood test he was shocked
many of these young guys had the hormone
levels and inflammatory markers of men
several decades older than them old man
blood parsley called it
because their training exercises and
missions often begin at odd hours of the
night and required them to stay awake
for 24 hours or more at a stretch they
were chronically sleep deprived their
natural sleep wake Cycles utterly
disrupted when Kirk told me the story I
experienced a jolt of recognition too I
I too had had old man blood during my
not thin Peter phase this earlier part
of the book where you were uh not you
were in good shape swimming freaking to
Catalina Island but you're also a
metabolic disaster and not looking as
lean as you should according to your
wife who said you should try to be a
little what'd you say a little less not
thin with elevated insulin high
triglycerides and a testosterone level
in the bottom five percent of men in the
United States I'd always attributed my
poor health and hormone imbalance to the
point of my at that point to my lousy
diet and diet alone but I had also spent
at least a decade in a state of severe
sleep deprivation in residency and
afterward belatedly I realized that not
sleeping had actually caught up to me as
well it was probably even evident in my
face Studies have found that people who
sleep less chronically tend to have
older looking flabbier skin than people
their same age who sleep more now I
recognize that sleep diet and risk of
long-term diseases are all intimately
connected to each other knowing what I
do now I would bet that a few months of
perfect sleep could have fixed 80
percent of my problems back then even on
a crappy diet
sleep
and I remember you know just to make
sure people understand why I make such a
bold statement there because I was
exercising 28 hours a week yeah in other
words I look back at that and say how is
it that with so much exercise I was
still you know in the state I was in and
I think that there are extreme cases
with extreme sleep deprivation where you
know because the old saying the old
adages can you out exercise a bad diet
and the traditional thinking is no the
truth of it is you could if you can
exercise enough like when I was growing
up I could clearly out exercise a bad
diet because I had the world's worst
diet and I was probably six percent body
fat and fit as a fit like I mean I look
like a specimen and you also had
freaking like high testosterone of
course so there's clearly a scenario
when you can but the difference is like
it I couldn't exercise that much today
if my life depended on it you know I
mean I asked this question of
a couple of our mutual friends right who
were former seals who live in Austin now
and one night we were having dinner this
is probably like a year or two ago and I
was like okay I get from having talked
to enough of you guys that like getting
through buds is mostly here like you
know I get that well you guys are no
more mentally you guys are probably at
least as mentally strong today as you
were then could you get through buds
today and every one of them said no
and the reason is they said we don't
physically recover the way we used to
like we couldn't do that volume of
suffering today in our late 40s and
early 50s and so that's why I just think
the strategy of I'm gonna out exercise
my bad diet like that strategy will not
work Beyond a certain age and that age
is pretty young
sleep introduces another wrinkle to that
which is really bad sleep and really bad
diet there's no there's no out
exercising that at any point either yeah
I think when uh when it comes to females
going through SEAL training I think one
of the things that's going to be very
problematic is the ability to recover
quickly enough because they just don't
have like the testosterone I don't think
they have the hormones to to recover
because you are getting a beat down you
are getting annihilated and it's hard
six months right six months yeah and
what I think would happen is I think
that what would happen was if you took
an extremely fit
person which I had a actually was life
life and I were having a discussion this
discussion as a matter of fact and tia
Claire to me who's a CrossFit Champion I
mean just an incredible specimen of a
woman just badass
and I was saying I said you know I mean
you take someone like tear I mean I said
she got she can deadlift more than me
and he's like no she can't I was like
bro
she's she's like a professional athlete
of course you can blah blah and um and
uh
and he's like no there's no way and I'm
like I bet she can he's like I bet she
can't we looked it up and her deadlift I
think it was you know 405 you know which
is a little freaking outstanding for a
girl but for a man that's pretty normal
right right it's pretty normal but so so
but it's still like so she's in the
she's in the ballpark right she's in the
ballpark
but if you um
I think what would happen with a female
in Seal training is
that like they give you the weekends to
recover
but you're barely recovered on Monday
morning barely and then you you go
another week and you have to recover
again and again and again and I think
what would happen is someone is buds the
worst of it as far as as far as the
physical uh demand and the the recovery
or lack thereof it's not it's not well
it's not because you'll go overseas and
you'll be in some situation where you'll
be getting crappy nutrition and even
worse sleep or just as bad sleep and
you'll be nervous and like it's gonna be
worse it's going to be worse uh so
that's what I think would happen is I
think I think they would need recovery
time and they just wouldn't have they
wouldn't be able to keep up over they
probably they'd probably be in the top
20 on the runs and swims in the first
week they'd be in the top 40 in the runs
and swims in the second week they'd be
in the bottom 50 in the third and fourth
week and then and then they just would
continue to go down and what was the at
the at the worst of your training I
assume hell week was the biggest sleep
deprivation you've ever experienced in a
in a training not not in real life yeah
it is and is hell week
30 years ago the same as hell week today
in terms of sleep deprivation damn close
okay yeah yeah yep it's it's for yes
it's the same it's the same they'll
sleep
they sleep a couple hours and usually
why they put you to sleep is to get
people to quit because on you know
you've been awake for Sunday and then
Monday and then Tuesday and then they'll
come and say like Hey listen we just got
in trouble with the commanding officer
and he says we've been too hard on you
guys and he's now told us that you guys
need to you guys are going to get six
hours of sleep and you have to get dry
so go put on dry clothes and you guys
will see you in six hours
and then you're like oh of course you
put on dry clothes and you crawl into
bed and then 20 minutes later or an hour
later or 40 minutes later they're in
there with Bourne sending you right back
the surf's on a bunch of people like I'm
out dude I'm not getting back into this
game so and they do that a couple times
they do that or something like that so
that's why they let you sleep they let
you sleep so that you have to wake up
and go back into hell so that's a
transitional period that something how
much use is there of stimulants
uh what kind of stimulants modafinil uh
you know Ritalin things like that
none do they check guys for that or like
I mean in your day and age those things
weren't popular but today those are very
popular drugs that any high school kid
could get a hold of do you have any idea
if they're they drug test the [__] out
of these kids they do so you're getting
drug tested during Halloween I don't
know if they drug test them during hell
week but certainly after how weak and
prior to hell week you're you're getting
drug tested a lot
um how much do you eat during hell week
as much as you want you eat it well yeah
you eat a ton you eat a ton that's that
so you're not limited on nutrition nope
you're you're basically and then um
um coffee you can have coffee
I don't know
I did I didn't drink coffee I still
don't drink coffee and I don't know if
you could drink coffee I don't think you
can I don't think you can drink coffee
during a week
but I don't know by the way there must
be a real difference between if you get
your if you're doing your hell week in
January versus August there's a big
difference is the dropout rate
significantly higher in January it's
higher it's higher for sure I mean it's
you know the deal to San Diego it can be
37 degrees yeah you know it could be 37
degrees the interesting thing is what is
it in the winter hell weeks
the the cold so you'll get more quitters
in summer hell weeks they'll get more
chafing and more swelling
and more disease
but more people will make it because
cold is it what month did you do it
spring I think May
late May
and here's the other thing like when
you're when it's winter time they check
the water temperature they put you in
that water until someone's getting
hypothermia
oh so you'll spend less time in the
water from January so that means in the
winter time you're running more you're
doing more and some for depending on who
you are because some people you know
that did cross country they don't care
if they run they'll run all day some
people that did water polo they'd rather
swim there's some people when you go to
a pool Evolution it's it's a rest for
them I was very comfortable with my
water any of the pool not the swims but
not tying pool comp well I failed pool
comp but uh life-saving those kind of
things drown proofing I was they were
like a break for me some people were
absolutely horrified of those things uh
some people you know you take a kid that
ran cross country in college he's doing
a Four Mile time run there's no doubt
that he's going to pass and he's going
to be fine a guy that swam in college or
played water pool he's going to pass
those swims really easily so people
depending on what your strengths are
you'll have some time where it's you'll
get a little reprieve
um but they'll find your weakness too
because no one is good well just about
no one is good at everything and even
and you will get some studs you'll get
some freaking guys that are complete and
utter studs and occasionally make them
sometimes they quit
sometimes they quit because they lost
something for the first time you know
they never lost a race before and that's
too much for them they never failed pool
comp like I did you know I failed all
kinds of stuff in my life so I felt pool
compost like cool what I need to do to
fix it
um but the sleep deprivation thing
you know some people have bad
hallucinations and stuff and I didn't
really have
I had like one hallucination you know as
we were paddling our boat and I looked
across the ocean I found I saw a traffic
light and I was like and I knew it I was
like well there's we're in the ocean so
there's no traffic light I'm just
hallucinating and it wasn't that big of
a deal I recovered from Hell Week pretty
quickly
and like I said I've always been I'm I'm
very functional without sleep as well
very functional like when I hear uh Matt
Walker and he'll say you know if you've
had less than five hours of sleep
you cannot you're basically it's
equivalent of four beers or it's
equivalent of whatever
that is just not true with me and it's
not true with many of my friends too
it's not true with many of my friends or
at least a decent amount of my friends I
I just went out to I I was
I did an event in Las Vegas got on a red
eye
slept two hours on the red eye arrived
at my next gig and was speaking and
interacting and answering questions for
eight hours
like literally no Factor literally no
factor and and so I don't know I think
there's some a little bit of
exaggeration or something with that or I
don't know am I wrong
I mean I don't know exactly what the
stats are I kind of forget but it's um
I don't think it's four beers I think
it's
is it four hours is equal to a blood
alcohol of
0.08 maybe that sounds about right
yeah baby yeah there's no doubt there
has to be there has to be personality
what you get some alcohol be I'm a
different man
you want to see some changes bro and it
could be no sleep lack of sleep it's
gonna be gets to get me on the sauce get
me on the fire water and I'll you'll
meet a different Jocko all day when did
you stop drinking basically when I
retired yeah so that was in 2010 and I
didn't like yeah there wasn't like yeah
just all of a sudden I wasn't hanging
around with a bunch of my friends
anymore and I I just stopped and I
looked up and I was like well no point
in doing that anymore I mean and I well
at the World Cup I had a I had a
Guinness you know I I don't I don't like
the taste of alcohol anymore at all I
don't have any desire for it and man
I've seen it just destroy so many people
that I just can't I can't get on board I
can't give money to that industry I just
can't do it I'm I'm I'm I'm becoming
more and more anti-alcohol every you
know every moment of my life now and and
look I I've been kind of giving the
caveat that you know I had a lot of fun
and bonded with the guys and I've
started to just like kind of kind of
think about that too and think well how
much fun would I been having if I wasn't
drinking what if I wasn't doing that
what would I have been doing what did I
miss out on so I'm even starting to
revoke that caveat a little bit as I get
older and and you know the culture was
very strong for alcohol in the whole
military and it was even stronger in the
SEAL Teams and you're a frog man that's
what we're doing and I was like cool
that's what we're doing I'm here I'm
here to be a frog man let's go that's
what we're doing I'm in and I'm gonna do
it hard so watch this
but thankfully I you know I always also
you know some people have the they say
oh I have an addictive personality and
it's almost like a humble brag
um like I have an addictive personality
I think you actually do have an
addictive personality to some things
yeah I don't think I have it like I'm
like okay cool I don't yeah I I can stop
doing something maybe jiu jitsu's a
little bit but but you know I go I go
times where I can't train and I don't
freak out about it so I don't think I
have an addictive personality and it
scares me when I think about people that
do have that it's scares me to think
about what it must be like
to want to drink alcohol or do whatever
thing so badly that you can't control it
that's that's very scary to me I think I
have a little bit of
I think I have a little bit of I like to
be in control of what's happening and
which is weird because when it comes to
leadership I don't have that at all I
don't need to be in control and everyone
that works for me will tell you like oh
yeah Draco is like he's crazy he'll let
me do whatever I want
because I had somebody say something to
me about that about me wanting you you
want to control stuff I'm like actually
I don't care
I talk to anyone that's ever worked for
me unless they were an idiot and I had
to micromanage them which is a very
small category of people but most people
they work for me they're like doing
whatever they want and I'm giving them
free reign and backing them up and
supporting them but for my personal life
I don't like to uh
feel like I'm going to lose control or
feel like I can't control something
that's happening so that's what scares
me about the oh it doesn't scare me but
the the Psychedelic you know voyages
that people are going on
because and the way I explained it to
some of my friends that have been on
these voyages and it's been very helpful
for them
and I've said like well I feel like I'm
driving down the road at 80 miles an
hour in my vehicle I don't think I need
to stop pull over to the side take apart
my engine put it back together again and
like hope I got it right it doesn't seem
like a worthwhile risk to me and I don't
feel like I have you know that
I don't feel bad or feel good I'm happy
so
um there there's my my thoughts but
sleep back to sleep
uh the the other thing is you can only
the short sleepers the genetic short
sleepers which I don't know if I'm one I
don't I don't really think I am because
it sounds like it's so rare that it
could be impossible that I could be one
I used to think it was genetic because
one of my kids is like the same way
doesn't need to sleep one of my kids my
oldest daughter doesn't need to sleep my
middle daughter
go pull her out of bed you know my wife
pulled her out of bed my son somewhere
in the middle my youngest daughter
pulled her out of bed
so I thought okay well that makes sense
different jeans
um but then when I hear how rare it is
that you're actually really a short
sleeper I'm like well then it can't be
me but I can survive for sure on a
pretty small amount of sleep without
really much inhibition and I don't think
that's cool
in fact I want I want to sleep more
I want to like let's go
uh but to your point which you explain
in great detail in the book there are
all kinds of negative impacts to not
sleeping enough
and you've got a section in here about
okay get the book go get the book
um but you know don't drink alcohol
don't eat anything less than three hours
before bedtime
abstain from electronics for at least
one hour before bed avoid doing anything
anxiety producing or stimulating such as
greeting work email or God help you
checking social media
uh for the folks that have access to a
sauna or a hot tub
go getting that before bed room should
be cool ideally in the mid 60s
I hate to sound like one of those people
that I I guess I am now but I have a
Asana
and I have a bed cooler thing and that
bed cooler thing is legit yeah it's
amazing it's freaking legit it and when
I had it's cold and so like I don't
really have like the crazy sweat
nightmares anymore
I guess they're more in Arctic
environments but it works out good uh
give yourself enough time to sleep
you call it sleep or scientists call it
sleep opportunity fix your wake up time
don't deviate it from it even on the
weekends
this is where I feel really lucky
because my boys especially the middle
one he's like
I mean this kid is on a clock he cannot
sleep past 6 a.m yep so we don't sleep
past six a.m you don't doesn't matter if
it's a holiday doesn't matter if it's a
weekday it doesn't matter if it's a
weekend
it's we're always up at six and uh
there's something good about that right
you you don't get into what's called
social jet lag which is when people try
to you know shortchange their sleep
during the week and then make up for it
on the weekends it doesn't work that way
yeah or you do the opposite this is what
I've always
advise people oh it's Friday night so
I'm gonna go out a little later I'll
sleep in okay so now you wake up at
eight and now it comes to 10 o'clock at
night you're not tired that's right
because you had more sleep so you stay
up until midnight and now you next week
until 10 and now you can't go to sleep
until one o'clock in the morning and now
you're for you're getting up early on
Monday and it sucks so
so there you go
um
get your sleep everybody from me
get your sleep definitely from the
doctor here get your sleep chapter 17.
work in progress the high price of
ignoring emotional health
health and this was the surprise chapter
on Tuesday July 11 2017 at 5 45 pm to be
exact I had received a call from Jill my
wife she was in an ambulance with our
infant son Arrington on the way to the
hospital for some reason he had suddenly
stopped breathing and Fallen unconscious
his eyes were completely rolled back in
their sockets and he was lifeless and
blue with no heartbeat only the quick
reaction of our Nanny had saved him she
rushed him to Jill who is a nurse her
Instinct took over she immediately put
him on the floor and began performing
CPR rhythmically but carefully pressing
her fingers on his tiny sternum as the
nanny frantically dialed 9-1-1 he was
barely a month old
by the time the firefighters stormed at
the house about five minutes later
Arrington was breathing again and his
skin was turning from Blue back to Pink
as oxygen returned to his body the
firemen were stunned we never see these
kids come back they told Jill to this
day we still don't know how or why it
happened but this is likely what occurs
when baby dies when babies die suddenly
in their sleep they choke for a moment
on their own saliva or some other insult
occurs and they ver and they're very
immature nervous systems fail to restart
their breathing when Joe called me from
the ambulance I was in New York in a
taxi on 45th Street on 54th Street on my
way to dinner
after she finished telling me what the
story I just said without a shred of
emotion
okay call me when you get to the
hospital so I can talk to the doctors in
the ICU
she got off the phone pretty quickly and
of course it's obvious why she was upset
our son had nearly died and the right
thing for me to say the only thing to
say was that I was getting the next
flight home
Jill stayed in the hospital with Aaron
alone for four days she pleaded with me
to come home I called in Daily to talk
to the doctors and discuss each day's
test results but I stayed in New York
with my important work
Aaron's Cardiac Arrest happened on a
Tuesday but I did not come back home to
San Diego until Friday
of the following week
10 days later
even today just thinking about what
happened I feel nauseous about my
behavior I can't believe I did that to
my family I can't believe what a blind
selfish checked out husband and father I
was and I know I may may never fully
forgive myself for it as long as I live
I must have been giving off very
troubled Vibe during this period because
around then my close friend Paul Conte a
medical school classmate who is now a
brilliant and very intuitive
psychiatrist began urging me to go to
this place in Kentucky
I looked it up and it seemed to be a
place for addicts this doesn't make
sense I told him I'm not an addict
he explained to me over several months
of gentle discussion that addiction can
take many forms not merely to drugs or
alcohol often he continued it's an
outgrowth of some trauma that has
happened in a person's past
Paul is an expert in trauma and he saw
that I displayed all the behavioral
signs anger Detachment obsessiveness a
need to achieve that was fueled by
insecurity
I don't know what it was that happened
but you just have to trust me on this he
said he was relentless
I agreed to go to Kentucky but I was
still looking for any excuse to get out
of it
in early November a woman from the
bridge which is the rehab place in
Kentucky called to do my intake
interview it was a long tedious
conversation and my patience finally
expired when she asked have you ever
been subject to any kind of abuse
I got so angry I yelled [__] you and
hung up the phone
after this call I decided to cancel my
planned stay what was wrong with these
people asking such idiotic questions
that Thanksgiving weekend was still a
blur
it's the only Thanksgiving in our life
together when we didn't go to dinner
with friends or family or host one
ourselves we just stayed home alone
on Sunday night Jill begged me to go to
again to go to Kentucky
I just can't go off the grid for that
long I said my patients need me and you
need me to help with the kids
this was total [__] and we both knew
it she replied Point Blank you're of no
help to me in fact you're hurting me and
your kids very badly
confronted with the brutal truth
I knew I had to go
so you go out to this place in Kentucky
um
you get out there you are you know
trying to
keep a low profile
I thought it was funny that you had
called out that you wanted a private
room you know because you're so
important and no you're going to get a
roommate I'm going to fast forward a
little bit after four or five days I
could no longer remain silent which is
what you had done for your first several
days they're not telling anybody
anything
they'd set aside almost an entire day
when we were all supposed to tell our
life stories from the beginning we had
an hour each and we were supposed to
prepare
so I was finally telling my life story
for the first time to this group of
perfect strangers not even Jill had
heard the whole thing
but I was telling it in a way that was
very matter-of-fact this happened when I
was five this happened when I was seven
and so on
some of it was sexual some of it was
physical
but it was not all bad I explained these
events terrible as they were had led me
to take up boxing and martial arts at
the age of 13 I got to punch bags people
and that channeled my anger I learned
how to protect myself but I also gained
discipline and focus qualities that
proved invaluable when around the age of
19 I pivoted from pugilism to
mathematics terrible as it was my past
was also what set me on the path to
becoming a doctor I continued growing
somewhat defensive
throughout College I volunteered at a
shelter for sexually abused teenagers
and I became close to many of them over
four years including one young woman who
had been abused by her father when she
attempted suicide one of my one of many
attempts I went to the to visit her in
the hospital
I was a senior by then and I had already
applied to the top PHD programs in
aerospace engineering but I wasn't
really sure it was my calling spending
so much time in the hospital with her
helped lead to the Epiphany that I was
meant to care for people not solve
equations so you see I concluded
parts of my past may have been bad but
in a way they also ended up setting me
on a course towards a better life some
of the kids I grew up with and boxed
with meanwhile were getting arrested for
armed robbery and getting girls pregnant
in high school and all kinds of other
stuff that could have easily been me so
in a way I said
my abuse may have actually saved my life
I don't really even need to be here
right then one of our therapists Julie
Vincent cut me off there are many rules
at the bridge and one of the most
important ones was no minimizing
you're not allowed to minimize anything
that someone else is saying and you're
especially not allowed to minimize your
own experiences
but she didn't flag me for that
instead she asked a simple question you
were five years old when this happened
first to you right that's right I
replied and your son Reese is almost
five years old right now right I nodded
so you're saying it's okay that this
happened to you and you were his age but
would you be okay with people doing that
to Reese now
another rule at the bridges you're not
supposed to hand anyone Kleenex when
they're crying
they're supposed to get up and fetch it
themselves
now it was my turn to stand up and walk
over the clean Xbox
it all came pouring out of me and
finally I was able to embrace why I was
there and begin the hard work of
unpacking the last 40 years of my life
foreign
when you're going to this place and you
show up there
you know they say like uh uh someone
that's going to Seal training
when you when you go there you know if
you're gonna quit or not like deep
inside you actually know do you think
you knew what was going to happen when
you went to this place
no
no I mean I was just I was just I was
just so angry you know I don't think
you know I wasn't really there on my
choice you know I mean
if I didn't go I was leaving the house
right and never coming back so
I think I just you know I just had so
much
anger that I
I wasn't thinking about anything other
than
just trying to get through the day and
this place is
wonderfully awful right I mean they
deprive you of everything they don't you
know you don't you don't have a phone
they take your books away there's
I mean
I I think I mentioned there the only
thing they let me indulge in was
exercise you know I could get up at 4 30
and they had this janky little
Universal machine somewhere in the
basement that like you know I could go
down and use and run in the woods like
that was it right so so aside from that
you're stripped of every defense
mechanism you have
um
but no I had no idea what I was in store
for
now I've felt like talking about combat
which I've done I mean basically because
I have a podcast and I I you know I I've
said that when my friends have died
I've often been the guy that's giving
the eulogy and matter of fact I have a
sop now if someone I know dies I'm
immediately writing because I don't know
if when you get the call or not but I'm
Gonna Be Ready
um and I found that to be very I think
that's very helpful
and so is this the first time would you
were able to like Express these things
that you had gone through growing up
yeah it's it's it's more than that
though right I think
stating them as facts is not really the
issue it's understanding
it's it's stop it's not justifying them
anymore right so I think again there it
wasn't like I didn't know this had
happened it wasn't like I blocked this
out it was that
you know bad things happen to everybody
and we come up with adaptations this is
a normal healthy important thing if we
don't adapt to bad things we're hosed
right like that's the end of our species
so
the only issue is how many of those
adaptations are positive how many of
those adaptations are negative
and
what I don't think I ever appreciated
was that all of the attributes of my
personality
um
that were positive and negative were
actually quite linked and they all kind
of stemmed from A coping strategy around
these issues of my childhood and
I think the first sort of
thing that I had to kind of realize in
that moment was
that the you know in this this place in
the the bridge they use a model right
where you have kind of um
you know you're born as a as a young
healthy child and then you you suffer
some sort of insult and they they talk
about this thing as the trauma tree
right so the trauma tree has branches
and Roots so the branches are the things
you see they're they're above the ground
right so the branches are addiction
codependency you know all the things
that we think of as you know
habituated survival strategies the roots
are the things beneath the surface
that's the trauma so that can be abuse
neglect and measurement witnessing
tragic events would be traumatic
and
the thing to figure out is how do we go
from sort of the young healthy child
into an Adaptive child
into a maladaptive adult and like what
does that transition look like and what
adaptations are serving you well and
which ones aren't
and I think that was really you know a
big part of the takeaway right which was
many of those adaptations have served me
incredibly well
um
but some of them haven't some of them
have been very destructive
and you know we were talking earlier
about alcohol well I feel very fortunate
but like you I mean I can't I can't
actually relate to somebody who drinks
alcohol through addiction
um so there's very different chemistry
in people's brains there are some people
for whom
ethanol triggers a pleasure Center in
them the way I can't relate to so you
know drugs alcohol gambling
these things have never resonated with
me those aren't my addictions
it just so happens that my addictions
are very socially acceptable
I mean work is a very socially
acceptable addiction perfectionism is a
very socially acceptable addiction
um
anger can be tolerated
uh provided you can sort of keep it in
check which I mostly could
um
but again you know as as the the story
you read at the outset displays I mean
it can get to a point where you're so
detached
um and you're so addicted to you know
work and you know
your own sort of narcissistic beliefs
um that you know the destruction is just
enormous around you know to those who
are closest to you
again it's not it's not visible to the
outside world but it's it's absolutely
visible to the people closest to you
so you go here
um you get you get
I would say from from what you write in
the book it's sort of
get it's moves you in the right
direction
it does yeah I leave early I only stay
for 14 days
and
most people believed I needed to be
there for six weeks
um
but I begged to go and they they relent
fast forward a little bit here
um
we're into covet times
2020.
as March bled into April it became clear
there was no end in sight
one day in late April 2020 I was on a
Routine Morning Call with my practice
manager when I couldn't take it anymore
and started venting
I've lost control I told her I can't
keep my patients stories straight
anymore was it patient X or patient y
who just last week told me about his
daughter's struggle at school was a
patient a or patient B whom I needed to
reach out to that evening about an issue
she was having
she tried to soothe me saying I was
doing the best I could under the
circumstances and that our patients were
grateful but the more she talked the
angrier I got
and just like that I spun into a radical
self-destructive episode one like I've
never experienced before or since even
remembering it now is terrifying I threw
a table across our living room
I tore my t-shirt to pieces I screamed
in Rage in pain
my wife begged me to leave the house for
fear I would harm her or the kids
I thought about driving myself into a
bridge abutment or some other structure
fast enough that I'd be killed
I was convinced that I was broken
defective
when they autopsied my brain they would
discover just how screwed up I was I was
beyond fixing nothing could make it
right
I ended up holed up in a motel on the
phone with Paul Esther and Terry they
insisted that I needed to go back to a
place like the bridge
now true to form I stubbornly disagreed
claiming that I could fix this with just
a little more time and support if only I
could get home and get some rest after
pleading with them for 48 hours I
finally relented in the middle of the
night I drove myself to Phoenix Arizona
to be admitted into a place called
psychological counseling services or PCS
Terry had been telling me about PCS for
nearly a year he said it was a place
that worked miracles healing wounds that
seemed Beyond permanent
I asked how he could be so sure he said
I just needed to trust him
so you head out there fast forward a
little bit on my second day
I was assigned to write a list of 47
affirmations representing one positive
statement about myself for each year of
my life I made it to about five or six
before I got completely stuck
for days and days I couldn't come up
with anything good to say about myself
my perfectionism and my shame did not
permit me to believe anything nice about
myself I just couldn't do it finally on
the 19th day a blistering hot Wednesday
morning it happened one of my therapist
Marcus was pushing deeper and deeper
into a story I told him earlier about
how it stopped wanting to celebrate my
birthdays when I was about seven in fact
I revealed I would keep my birthday a
secret until well into my twenties his
question made it clear that this was not
something a healthy child would do and
it likely masked something more deeply
wrong he just kept digging and would not
let it go
that recognition pushed me into an
emotional free fall it had been two and
a half years in the making but I finally
was able to let go and accept the truth
about my past and how it shaped me
without any excuses or rationalizations
all that I had become good and bad was
in response to what I experienced it
wasn't simply the Big T traumas either
we uncovered many many more little T
traumas hidden in the cracks that it
affected me even more profoundly
I hadn't been protected I hadn't felt
safe my trust had been broken by people
who were close to me I felt abandoned
all of that had manifested itself as my
own self-loathing as an adult
I had become My Own Worst Enemy and I
hadn't deserved any of it this was the
key insight that little sweet boy did
not deserve any of it
and he was still with me
once I had accepted all of this it was
easy to write out the 47 affirmations
so when you're going through this with
these
people with these therapists
was it was what what happened so what's
going on like I literally don't know
what this looks like like explain it to
me if I never seen a boxing match before
what is going on with these therapists I
know we get it you get into the
dialectical behavior therapy DBT
what does this look like
well PCS is set up as um
about
80 percent individual therapy about 20
group therapy you're doing therapy
from
seven in the morning till
seven at night every day
30 minutes for lunch basically seven
days a week most people go there for one
week I was there for three so I was
there for 21 straight days
um
which man I went through I went with
three different groups so I I basically
did the same thing effectively but with
three different groups of people but I
had the same individual therapist so we
were kind of going deeper and deeper and
deeper and again
um you know I didn't want to stay for
three weeks but I also knew from the
last time
like I'm gonna surrender a little bit on
this one and I'm gonna I'm gonna stay as
long as they tell me I need to stay this
time
um and so at the end of that second week
I really thought I was there
um
and then my friend Paul called me the
night before I was supposed to leave and
said
we think you need another week and I was
like
I can't do another week of this like I
just can't do any more of this and
you know he just said like
you gotta trust me and
I did and it and it made sense because
of what happened in that last week like
that
you know there's the uh and I there's a
quote in there about
um
you know the stone cutter hitting the
stone right and it's like
on that 101st you know hit the stone
breaks and it looks like well he did
nothing for the first hundred no the
first hundred were just as essential to
that one so even though I think kind of
everything really came together for me
on that 19th day it goes back to two and
a half years earlier in Kentucky and all
the work that had happened in that two
and a half year period of time but it it
really
it just it really came together on that
one one that moment and and through you
know Marcus's real probing and um
and it was more into the little T stuff
truthfully right it wasn't into the big
obvious stuff at this point what's a
little t look like yeah I mean it's it's
you know it's it's um in my case I think
it was more around
um
not not having a dad around probably was
was the most formative thing that I had
just never assumed mattered I just
didn't think that that meant anything
um
and I I think I finally came to accept
the fact that you can't use a totally
rational brain of a 40 year old to try
to explain what a two-year-old a
three-year-old a four-year-old
five-year-old experience they don't
process things that way
um and I think once I came to understand
that
I just stopped making any excuses you
know I think there was always still some
lingering excuses and they were really
standing in the way of
um
doing this this kind of work that needed
to be done so would an excuse be well I
get mad but this is the way I was
treated well as a kid so that's just the
way I am is that the type of excuse
we're talking about
um
no I mean no so so an excuse I mean yes
that could be but that would so it would
more be um
hey you know I might not have had this
kind of attention as a kid but it
doesn't matter because
you know
I wasn't getting beat to a pulp every
single day like there was always sort of
a way like it wasn't that bad it was you
know
um or another excuse could be
um
so that that's an excuse towards what's
happening to you another excuse could be
like
you know I have a horrible temper but
like I don't hit my wife or my kids so
therefore it has no effect on them
right like yeah they see me like
screaming at a driver
um or pulling a guy out of his car and
almost killing him but I mean like I'm
not hurting them uh and not realizing of
course how you know illogical that is
I guess it's because kovid was going on
but like I remember exactly when this
was happening because you and I were
talking all the time like
um yeah and and it's weird for me
because
like seem normal
and you you told me like I can't
remember you told me before or after
you you you went I don't remember if you
told me hey I'm going somewhere
or if you told me after I just got back
from somewhere but I remember you
indicating that you had gone and you
said something along the lines of like
hey I'm not addicted to anything but I
need to get some [__] sorted out type
thing that's the thing and I was like
okay cool
um but I the reason I'm saying that is
because from just to just to your point
that from the outside
I didn't have any like look that I think
like for Peter gets pretty pissed when
he you know misses a shot or whatever
sure but you know whatever I didn't
think that was uh any kind of like deep
issue you know
um so from my perspective again
to be aware of your friends and pay more
attention
so that you can help out is a good thing
to do and obviously in the veteran world
we need to do that
but clearly it's not just veterans that
go through trauma Big T trauma Little T
trauma whatever and might need some
freaking support sometimes
and who knows like
you know like to talk a little bit about
you know if you see someone that's doing
this kind of stuff like losing their
temper or they're they're doing things
that you think that's a little weird
that seems a little strange like just to
be like dude what's going on are you
good
I don't know I feel like a bad friend
you know to not maybe just be a little
bit more
um proactive
yeah I mean I I don't know I mean look I
think you know Paul Conte was able to
see that because he's literally one of
the smartest psychiatrists on the face
of the Earth like I I just don't know
that a normal
smart a normal otherwise smart person
could could sort of put those patterns
together so I I you know I just feel
lucky that that you know
and again Paul
I remember him saying this he's like you
just live your life like a trauma victim
and I was like what the hell are you
talking about I'm not a trauma victim
and he goes
I okay but I'm just I'm just telling you
like you walk like a duck you quack like
a duck it's possible you're a duck
um and that's a functional alcoholic but
you're a functional trauma because
you're freaking highly functional I mean
damn you know like you're just kicking
ass across the in in so many different
aspects of life for extended period of
time
you know like
hard to see
how often were you around
uh quite a lot right because Paul and I
shared an office in New York
um so I probably saw Paul more than any
friend
you know during like a five-year period
of okay you know 2015 to 2020 and
but but again he knew me in med school
like he's he's known me forever he he
understands
um
yeah he just understood the the
perfectionism the rage the the constant
need to prove myself
um and again I think it's
I'm I'm not here to suggest that like
striving isn't good or any other things
like that that's not that's not the
point here right the point is at what
point do these things become maladaptive
right and there you could take someone
else who's working just as hard as me
who's
you know just as committed to excellent
work but it's not coming from this place
of insecurity it's coming from a place
of love and it could be a totally
different experience and it's not
destroying their life I mean the point
here is it was destroying my life that's
the point that's another thing that
matters is uh and that's why again this
chapter is not written as like
you need to do this it's it's not a you
need to do this it's
this is a story that I hope lets you
examine yourself
um because there is no question in my
life that I was
like there was just a a trail of body
bags around me if you wouldn't have gone
gotten this help or you you're getting
divorced your wife wasn't going to see
you anymore she was going to get custody
of the kids you were gonna get pissed
off you were going to stop working so
much like everything is going to fall
apart that's the trajectory we were on
I mean I don't think I would be alive
today
because because shame is really the
problem here right shame is the shame is
the thing that that kind of uh underpins
all of this stuff right and that's so EV
every time you make a mistake
at least in my case every time I would
make a mistake I would hammer myself
harder for it right like so for example
let's go back to when I come home from
that trip 11 days or 10 days after my
son is almost dead
do you think I'm acting better or worse
as a result of that
like the logical person would say oh my
God you must have been bending over
backwards to be a better husband after
you were such a dick
but that's the logical person no no the
reality of it is you feel the shame for
how you've behaved so you come home and
you act worse
again shame is an awful thing how do you
act worse like what do you do yeah just
more aloof more distant more of a dick
more Gruff
less helpful
probably went back on the road three
four five days later
are you in your mind thinking well I'm
just like such a beast of a human that I
just this stuff doesn't phase me and I'm
just carrying on
I don't you know it's funny I wish I
knew I wish I could go back and find out
what lies that guy was telling himself
prob probably your job is to provide
like your job is to be the financial
provider
not to do not provide any emotional
support
so
this you you explain this story um you
know obviously like I said get the book
but what is a beautiful thing is it says
this
uh one section it says if you take
nothing else from my story take this
if I can change
you can change
and
you know this is you're talking about
this specific kind of emotional side of
it but it's really all aspects of health
and of life and
that idea right there
if I can change you can change and by
the way you have health issues earlier
in the book you have uh metabolic issues
earlier in the book you have
opioid do you talk about opioid in this
book I don't know if you do no no
but you talked about the last time
you're online podcast like you have been
through really bad spots
in just about every aspect or potential
way a person can be in bad spots and yet
you've figured out
that you can change
this one's the hardest
this was the only one I really thought
couldn't be changed
um I always had confidence the others
could change
I always felt like I could bend the Ark
in anything else this was the only one
where I was like this is truly
unchangeable
um
I've I've never had a stronger belief in
my life stronger than the belief in
gravity
that I could not change this this set of
traits in myself
that these these were hard wired into my
motherboard at Birth
when's the last time you lost your
temper
well never in a destructive way
since 2020.
now I I won't like let me be completely
clear
three days ago is the first time in
three years I got mad at another driver
and honked at them and yelled at them
was this in traffic or is this on the
race course no no it was just we just it
was a I was at the airport in San Diego
and I went to get the car and I'm
driving back to get pick up my family in
a bus cut me off
and I was like all right so I pull out
of the way
and then I go to go around them the
other way and then the bus like almost
smashed me into a wall so I pull out and
I'm like
I mean I just got super pissed in that
moment and
um you know I'm hot I'm like literally
laid on my horn for 30 seconds right
like how do you not see a vehicle you
literally almost put me into the wall
um
and that's the first time I've had like
road rage in three years and what was
your debrief to yourself after that
um I went through kind of like okay
what what made what what else was what
West was really bothering you that day
because you've been cut off a thousand
times in the last three years and you've
never cared so what is it about that day
and secondly did you figure that out
um
yes I think this is the this time really
was almost really resulted in an
accident like it's a if there's an
asymmetry when a bus is almost cutting
you off
um
also this sounds dumb and I don't know
if this justifies any of it but in my
mind it's like this was an airport bus
at the airport like you should know your
way around the airport you shouldn't be
weaving in and out of lanes with
concrete on either side like there was
sort of an expectation
um
but regardless it was on my mind like
for a couple days I was really like
examining this and here's another thing
I've learned like you have to forgive
yourself
like I'm not I'm not here to sound
perfect
but I'm here to say that I'm not going
to let one mistake spiral into 20. so
the you know I say this to my patients
all the time
don't beat yourself up if you miss your
workout for a day
but just don't miss it two days in a row
just get back in the gym the next day
don't worry about it
if you eat if you if you go on vacation
and eat like crap come back and start
eating well
don't let a mistake spiral into Infinite
mistakes and so
in many ways it comes back to this idea
of Shame right it's really tempting for
me to just berate myself in shame
because of my misbehavior but instead it
was like you know what
that's like not a proud moment for me
like I'm not proud of the fact that I
laid on the horn and yelled at someone
who by the way doesn't hear me but it
doesn't matter the point is like I'm not
proud of how I acted and
I'm gonna do better next time
but just by doing that I can do better
next time
right that didn't it didn't real and
I'll tell you what I was most proud of
is about 30 seconds after that I picked
up my family
and I was totally fine whereas
like three years ago that would have
ruined the day
I would my wife would have got in the
car I'd have been like you wouldn't
[__] believe what just happened this
[__] idiot I'm gonna go find them
but instead like to this day my wife
might hear this podcast but she would
otherwise have no idea what just took
place so it's just like we're done with
that
so you know it's a little bit of a
setback but there's a victory
I know that you posted a video the other
day after you dry fired my bow and
you're like hey I click on it you start
off with something like this is progress
I was like oh no
and then and I was thinking the same
thing I was like oh and then you explain
it you're like hey you know what I it
was really dumb and I just feel
shouldn't do it and you know what it's
okay
yeah I mean like I had I dry fired a bow
in April of 2021 it was last time I
drive fired a bow
and
I mean and I that was after going
through all of this and
I did okay
but I had to go jump into an ice bath
like that was the own and I still
screamed I was so pissed when I broke it
um but prior to that when I drive fired
a bow like 2019
I smashed the bow after
like so you know people listening might
not understand what happens when you
drive fire a boat you've already broken
the string the cams and the limbs
well then I just broke the boat I was
like I just I'm gonna destroy this bow
everything is gone
um so yeah like I I think that's like
literally the thing if you were to say
like what are the three things you're
most proud of in the last 12 months I
literally would put that on on those the
top three driver on their boats try
firing a boat and within
three minutes
first of all not yelling not screaming
not throwing anything and within three
minutes being okay it's so crazy that
you're a freaking grown ass man that's a
doctor uh this look at your life
incredible and you do that kind of [__]
it's like oh you did that kind of [__]
it's like it's kind of crazy right isn't
that kind of crazy yes it's so hard to
like picture that
I have a friend named JP Danelle do you
know JP is I know you do remember my
friend JV Dale who's in the SEAL Teams
with me he was um very young when he
worked for me
and
like I see he he's you know had a bad
temper
and at one point I was like hey man
losing your temper is a weakness
and we broke it down you know like later
because we look at our dads right and
you're like oh when when my dad loses
his temper it's like a force it's like a
thing it's like no one no all of a
sudden economy turns into like a weird
Superman character because now everyone
cows to cows down to his behavior and
everyone gets out of the way and it's
just like so you see that you go I'm
gonna get that superpower
and that was what JP grew up with like
oh you know that's a power and
I was like hey man when when you lose
your temper it's a weakness
and that impacted him
because he never saw it that way and and
I I don't even remember when I figured
that out I don't really remember when I
figured that out but it was I was in the
seal themes and I you know probably saw
some idiot officer freaking lose their
temper and start yelling and screaming
and everyone little platoon going what
an idiot and I remember thinking I will
never do that you will never see me lose
control of my emotions that's that's a
bad thing and then just
never let that happen again
that's that's like
uh I think Echo Charles has a similar
story where Echo Charles realized at
some point that losing your temper he
read it in a book actually he read in a
book that losing your temper was a sign
of you know insecure that's what it was
for him it was he he read in a book that
losing your temper was a sign of
insecurity and he's like I'm never going
to lose my temper again and you know I
haven't seen Echo loses temper once in a
long time but
that's just yeah it's just so weird to
think about that and think about
um how negatively that can impact you
when you when you uh
you see your kids lose their temper
how do you how do you help them see the
the uh
the problems that it causes and I guess
how old are they uh just turned six and
we'll be nine at the end of the summer
and Olivia's already what 14 14. so
she's good to go
um so yeah six years old they're kind of
not quite there yet but nine it's like
if you're losing your temper at nine
we can start discussing
how that's going to impact you
so do you have any conversations like
that what do you do when they lose their
temper
yeah I mean look it's
um you know one of the great questions
you can ask a kid when they're
misbehaving in general after the fact is
how how did that impact the outcome
right as opposed to just saying don't do
that right it's like okay you made a
choice to act a certain way there were
repercussions from how you acted
how did it work out for you
um
and
that that's one lesson I've taken away
another lesson that I think every parent
knows is
the most important thing to do when a
kid is losing it and this is not easy to
do but it's important thing to do is to
not lose it yourself
I get asked uh like what you hey how do
you discipline your kids what's your
favorite way of discipline do you you
know do you beat them do you make them
do burpees do you whatever you know
they've got a bunch of and and
I got asked that a while ago and I was
like I can tell you my favorite form of
discipline with children
my kids my favorite form of discipline
was asking them questions
because when you say exactly what you
did like hey that make you feel better
how's it how's that outcome how's that
how'd that help you
how's that make you look what do you
think everyone's thinking of you right
now that you laying on the floor crying
when you're seven or you're storming off
the field when you're 10 or whatever the
case may be
asking questions is powerful discipline
disciplinary tool for children
um like I said there's so much of this
the you cover which we didn't even touch
on we didn't cover the actual tools that
you use that you got taught
to to handle this to you have tools that
you learned to utilize just like I could
teach you how to shoot a bow you got
taught what to do when your temper
starts to flare up when you start
feeling certain emotions and it's all in
the book and it's so worthwhile
to read that for yourself and for your
family and for everybody around you that
you can there's tools that you can
utilize
to come to overcome those things
um
but you know what I'm going to fast
forward a bit and kind of close this
thing out I mean we've been in here I
think approaching four hours uh
you write this
as my recovery progressed I noticed my
preoccupation with dying began to fade
away and my quest for longevity no
longer felt like a grim desperate task
now the things I did every day felt
welcome necessary I was enhancing my
life and looking forward to the future
my journey to outlive finally had
Clarity purpose and meaning
it brought me back to something my dear
friend Rick Alias had told me
Rick had been one of the 155 passengers
on U.S Airways flight that emergency
landed in the Hudson River in January of
2009 as the plane was coming down Rick
and most of the other passengers were
certain that they were going to die
only the Pilot's skill and more than a
little luck prevented disaster
if the plane had been going down if the
plane had been going a little faster it
would have broken a power on impact and
few miles per hour slower and the nose
would have tipped forward and it would
have sunk into the river
a handful of tiny factors like that made
the difference between everyone on that
plane living and many or most or all of
them dying
that day changed Rick's outlook on
longevity in a way that really resonates
with me
all that time I had been obsessed about
longevity for the wrong reason
I was not thinking about a long healthy
life ahead instead I was mourning the
past
I was trapped by the pain that my past
had caused and was continuing to cause I
wanted to live longer I think only
because deep down I knew I needed more
Runway to try and make things right
but I was only Looking Backward not
forward
I think people get old when they stop
thinking about the future Rick told me
if you want to find someone's true age
listen to them
if they talk about the past and they
talk about all the things that happened
and that they did
they've gotten old
if they think about their dreams their
aspirations what they're still looking
forward to
they're young
here's to staying young
even as we grow older
so
uh
that's the book
that's some good advice
from the doctor
um
and you give away advice all the time
you're still doing that now
that's what you're doing now
what currently what are you doing tell
us what you're doing where we can find
you
well my podcast the drive still comes
out every week so that's you know
continue to be a huge Joy we're about
five years into that and I we we've come
no closer to running out of topics to
explore uh than we were five years ago
so I see no end insight to that
um and we have recently uh launched what
we soft launched it it'll be kind of
rolled out a little bit more this year a
product called early which is sort of a
digital
um
uh I don't know how to describe it other
than kind of a master class of
everything we do in the practice so this
is something that took us two years to
build
um and it's
it's it's it's
truly the this is all you need to know
to to do all this and it you know it's
God it's probably 30 hours of Highly
produced video plus tons of downloadable
material and stuff like that so we had a
very limited release of it in April
where we put it out for four days just
to our subscribers we're gonna have
another release later the year and then
probably open it up to the public in the
beginning of 2024 because your practice
we've mentioned your practice but your
practice is helping people have better
health Span in lifespan yeah but it's
super small and it's effectively closed
right I mean at this point it's it's
sort of a friends and family but this is
a way for a normal person to say all
right I read this book because look what
we covered today I barely dusted on
anything that's in the book today like
it's freaking 410 pages of dense awesome
information we barely touched on any of
it uh and once you get done with that
book you're going to say to yourself I
need more
um so the podcast you have a
subscription version of the podcast as
well that's right so it's
um one episode a month is dedicated to
subscribers called an AMA and then um
and then the show notes are for
subscribers only so yeah we don't we
don't have any ads on our podcast it's
all forever
you're on Twitter
yeah Instagram more you're on Instagram
the most yeah you're on you have a
YouTube channel yep you have a Facebook
they're all they're all Peter attia MD
Peter at TMD he got it done he got it
done I let only because somebody had
Peter attia before I started oh yeah
otherwise I wouldn't have thought to put
the MD on there it seems a bit douchey
but
well luckily there was no other Jocko
willings back when I got a hold of my
stuff but um Ninjago willink MD
definitely definitely not that's for
sure Carrie sir you got echo's job right
now you got any questions I got an echo
question actually oh damn so you you
talked a lot in the book about sleep and
uh you know the the effect that has on
our ability to perform and things like
that I'm curious about uh your kind of
opinion on Mouse taping do you have an
opinion okay yeah it's it's really it's
really important for people who are
mouth breathers to to not be mouth
breathers so when you're breathing
through your mouth
be it awake or at sleep I mean you
basically want to reserve mouth
breathing only for when there is no
other option
which should really only be when you're
exercising strenuously and so if you're
sleeping in your mouth breathing it is
sending a message to your brain that
your energy requirements are significant
and you're in a more sympathetic state
so your sympathetic nervous system ramps
up your parasympathetic nervous system
goes down your heart rate goes up your
heart rate variability goes down so this
is a physiological State you don't want
to be in when you're trying to rest and
recover so again once you address any
structural issues that a person might
have in their nose being able to put on
mouth tape for people is an awesome tool
to teach them how to nasally breathe
right on and what are some of the
benefits of nasal breathing I I know
there are some I'm just not 100 sure
what they are I mean everything actually
starts I write a lot about sort of how
so much starts with the breath right so
your breathing strategy and there were
basically two major breathing strategies
your breathing strategy determines your
center of mass your center of mass
determines how you how you kind of exist
with gravity in in the world right so
are you hunched over are you sitting up
too much
um being in that high sympathetic low
parasympathetic state by itself is
counterproductive to your health so
that's that's really why you want to be
nasally breathing got it cool yeah JP
Danelle and I both we've been geeking
out about the mouth tape and we both do
it now when we sleep and yeah it's it's
been crazy beneficial for me I used to
wake up with headaches a lot of times
and because my mouth was like gaping
open when I was sleeping I guess but uh
it's it's been super helpful awesome
yeah I'm glad you I'm glad you asked
that question because that's the type of
information that you can get from from
your podcast from the drive podcast from
the book from the newsletter that you
sent out from everything so I'm glad you
like legit like that's I'm glad you
asked that because I spent all my time
talking about death and hell and all
this other stuff so
that's what I did but that's not what
you do for a living that's just the
stuff I wanted to talk to you about you
know as my bro uh Peter you got any
closing thoughts no guys this is uh it's
a privilege to sit down and be able to
go deep into this stuff
well uh thanks for joining us once again
I can't believe it's been seven years or
yeah something like seven years since
you came on this last time
um thanks for what you're doing too last
time I was on I was just starting to
write this book put it that way wow
crazy
uh thanks for what you're doing for so
many people you give away so much
information and everybody is should be
so appreciative of that thanks for your
friendship over the years man
um it's been very meaningful to me
uh but like your friend Rick said
after his exposure to death on that
seemingly doomed plane
I like to think more about the things we
will do in the future
um the hunting the shooting
the driving and the Mystery Mission the
mystery Mission which I got for you
which is going to be so freaking awesome
I got
Peter's wife asked his friends to send a
video with some things some request some
event that they were going to that we
would do with Peter individually
in the future sometime in the future in
the next five years and I couldn't think
of anything because what do you get what
do you do with Peter T like I was like
oh we go hunting oh we go shooting oh
wait there's a bunch of stuff I was like
yeah blah blah blah no offense to people
that said that because it'll be awesome
but I got struck with a bolt of
lightning of something that I know he
could never guess it's something that
he's been preparing for his whole life
but that he doesn't need to prepare for
but that's something that he's never
done before if you can imagine all that
and so do you remember how you worded it
in the video when I say uh so you gotta
remember my wife this is she asked me
what do you want for your birthday and I
said this is what I want I don't want
any presents I don't want to party I
want
I want an experience with each of my
friends and
um
and so it's this two hour video right
because you know every person's gonna
talk for a few minutes and it's amazing
and Jocko's is
I will call you with a pack list
and coordinates and a time to meet
and by the way he prefaced this with a
beautiful beautiful kind a lot of really
you know and it the ask wasn't what do
you have to say to Peter but a lot of
people did that anyway it was very kind
it meant a lot to me but after Jocko had
one of the sweetest things to say it was
this is the gift pack list coordinates
time be there right it's going to be
like it's going to probably be three
three days total with maybe a day of
travel
on either side or half day of travel so
it's gonna be awesome
um but that's what I like to think about
like your friend Rick advised I like to
think about what we're going to do in
the future we're going to do that we're
gonna do rock marches we're gonna we're
gonna do uh a lot of cool stuff in the
future and I think
as much as we can we will do our best to
stay young and outlive
thanks bro thank you
and with that Peter attia has left the
building and
well
freaking I legit I'm glad you asked that
question at the end because that's the
kind of knowledge that he is freaking
packed with and go listen to the first
podcast me the guy's life has been
he's been an overachievers all whole
life he just he is brilliant and he's
been focusing on this stuff
for decades and and he's willing just to
give it away so and I didn't do the best
job of like bringing forth that
information that's what the whole book
is filled with get the audiobook like do
you really want to hear me sit here and
and read the scientific parts of this
book I I was like well I could do that
or you can go get the audiobook and
listen to the doctor himself read it
that's what we did I'm glad you asked
that question so people recognize how
much information they can get uh from
him from his podcast from this book
outlive the science and art of longevity
yeah you got an opportunity you got
Peter T in the room man yeah something
cooking on the brain yeah you've been
taping that mouth Taping that mouth
breather up yeah bro me and JP Danelle
we've been geeking out about that man we
we both use the same like brand of tape
or whatever and uh it's been I think
we're getting your hostage tape on
that's what it is right yeah that's
that's the one we've both been using and
it works man uh not waking up all you
know headaches and bro I'm glad because
for so many years I've been running
around telling people hey quit being a
mouth breather right like what's your
problem
I didn't know there was some scientific
Truth for it right but guess what the
dog was right again man good mouth
breathe inside it's there's they're glad
you got that tape I was wanting to tell
you to get that tape boy
close that mouth boy
oh there was a guy that was a mouth
breather in the SEAL Teams but somehow
is his nickname wasn't mouth breather it
was fart sniffer because it kind of
looked like he was cut out his mouth
open like he was kind of like trying to
sniff that fart yeah pretty rough
nickname on my homeboy but you know yeah
that's the way it goes sometimes it's
crazy too I catch myself closing like
literally I'll be breathing through my
nose more throughout the day too and
I'll just notice it like my my mouth
closed I'm breathing through my nose I I
don't know if that's you know a
subconscious thing that's going on
because I said Improvement bro
I feel like that bad friend now that
didn't tell his buddy he had a booger
hanging out you know I should have been
like hey bro your mouth breathing all
right man step back and shut your door
shut your mouth man shut your mouth shut
off well your boy's on it we're getting
that taken care of right right there you
go Um well hey that's one of the many
ways we can try and become healthier uh
and live healthier live longer have a
better health span a better lifespan all
that stuff
so that's what we're doing need to get
the right fuel in your system by the way
you might as well go get that Jocko fuel
100 get that Jocko fuel hitter
uh what am I thinking about I'm thinking
about Mulk because because that's one
thing Peter was saying you gotta up that
protein you gotta up the protein your
muscles get that up that protein when it
tastes good and it's what is that word
satiating right it fills you up you
crack that Mulk and get it done RTD
style all right so RTD if you're not in
the industry that means ready to drink
you can get get some mocha just have it
in your house you can drink 30 grams of
protein like a boss two two minutes
yes it's a bit tasty and you know what's
crazy it's so it's filling you feel you
feel good
so get some of that and and look I'm
still old school with the pow pow get
the milk powder because if you're
feeling like you want a little bit more
you know like if you want a full-on meal
yeah yeah go get yourself get some of
the powder
um joint Warfare super Krill krill oil
vitamin D3 just we got it all for you
time War
Time Warner you want longevity bro you
want eyesight yeah
you get that talk it's a Time Warner get
the time more time Wars the
subscriptions for time war is crazy
right now because when you so when you
go to dockerfield.com you can you can
get it and then if you like it you can
subscribe to it so right now like once
people go on time War they're just
hitting that subscribe button just send
that [__] to me boy send it to me I was
I was digging into the Jocko system the
other day because I was tooling around
on fuel you know I'm getting some stuff
and yeah uh I was looking there's like
the Jocko system in the ecosystem and I
was like digging around George I was
like oh okay got the full stack yeah uh
there's go like in that system too so
all all the cool things we just
mentioned they're all like listed in
order in that in that stack so easy
access yeah time war is one of them I I
told you this before like I will take
time more until I die just the way that
what you get out of it from a from a
feeling good perspective to like the
joint solo and the eyesight thing was
crazy to me the eyesight thing was crazy
my eyesight got
legitimately better and like oh I must
have been about a second I have to look
at what what the Monster was because
that's when I noticed it but it's crazy
so anyways go to jocofuel.com get
yourself some of that uh if you don't go
to jockofuel.com you can go to Wawa you
can hook it up at Wawa bottom right
corner of that shelf they kind of we got
we got to put the squeeze got put on us
by
the big imperialistic
beverage companies you know who they are
I don't need to name them there's you
know who they are trust me but they went
paid millions of dollars to try and
subdue the rebels
try and take out the rebels we're out
there on what planet we're on Hoth or
some tattooing tattooing right we're out
there trying to be free trying to offer
people something that's actually good
for them they're trying to they're
trying to take us out with the Death
Star you can't deny performance Jamie
Cochran said that when she was on the
podcast the other day man and yeah uh
that's what I think about
are people clear shelves like you can't
compete with that you know you can't buy
that away from us that's the way it goes
down man look if not vitamin shop GNC
uh we're coming into a fees so all those
military commissaries across the world
be able to get your supply be able to
get it Hannaford Dash stores in Maryland
wake from ShopRite HEB
HEBs represent all you've all my people
down in Tejas just rolling in there and
just getting after it thank you
appreciate it you got a full Supply to
HEB we're sending it as fast as we can
Meyer up in the midwest Harris Teeter in
there now Lifetime Fitness in their
Shields rolled into Shields 300 000
square feet of just awesomeness go and
check that out and they also have Jocko
fuel they got everything you want
including Jocko Fuel and and by the way
we're in a bunch of little gyms small
gyms Jiu Jitsu gyms CrossFit Gyms we're
in there we're the we're the where the
energy drink across fit so when you get
done knocking out that Annie knocking
out that work out of the day before you
hit it you can get that energy drink
after you hit it you can get that Mulk
hit her get that protein in you if
you're if you own one of those gems you
want to sell Draco fuel
go to J or email JF sales at
jockofuel.com we can hook it up get that
wholesale account that wholesale account
rolling originusa.com
uh we just we just launched workout gear
hey it took a while I know trust me I
know trust me I know but to re-establish
a supply chain of American-made
materials so that we could cut and sell
it here in America took a little bit of
extra time then to design it properly
get the right materials it took some
time but we got it now RTX
Roll Train execute execute execute
uh you can get that you can get hunt
gear you can get Jiu Jitsu gear you can
get free you know what hoodies bro are
are hoodies American yes 100 right where
if you're in America you wear a hoodie
yes right you're just you have a hoodie
you probably got two get yourself one
more get yourself an American-made kilo
hoodie get the kilo get the kilo hoodie
the if you're if you're in the northern
part of the states get the heavy uh but
the kilo everywhere also you see you you
never lived in the northern part of the
states right because in the summertime
in the fall you don't need you don't
need that you the Heavies for the cold
weather you need that kilo
kilo hitter and look you live this is
what we were talking I was just I don't
know at a at a meeting with origin and
Jocko Fuel and they're like well you
know it's it's we're not going to be
selling many kilos right now because
it's the summer time and I was like bro
what are you talking about what are you
talking about in California you need to
you need a kilo year
back of the Jeep I've got two key like
two kilos you know after 7 P.M you throw
that little guy on you good but
California but but east coast same thing
you yeah I was in Maine when I was
growing up in Maine the sun goes down
guess what you need to put that kilo on
that kilo is a go-to piece of equipment
that should be with you at all times now
listen I'm not gonna lie to you I have a
blue kilo I have a black kilo blue Keel
is what I work out in the morning
black kilos kind of this wear around I
have a cami I have that Raptor kilo so
and look do I wear it when I'm out in
the woods yeah do I wear it when I'm
also rolling down down the streets hell
yeah do you wear is it roll it into the
podcast Studio every day yes yes yes I
do sure and then I have we have a zip up
one now too and I got one of those where
I found out about cool about the full
zip for travel
if you're traveling you may want to have
some variable warmth right so you uh it
may not sound like much but you just
unzip that bad boy and all of a sudden
let that coolness in or a little chill a
little chill coming through a little
wind no problem zip it up we're good get
that versatility with the kilo zip
hoodie dude I just invented that right
if you get hot unzip it I'm over here
smart yeah freaking technology it's from
giving Peter a tea a run for his money
on Intel on his intelligence because I
said if you get hot you can unzip your
hoodie check it out
originusa.com go get yourself an
American-made hoodie and wear it with
pride help your help the National
Security in this country and help your
children
live in a stable Free Nation
in the future that's what we're doing
originusa.com there you go also got
Jocko store jockostore.com you had one
job one job blew it on a jungle story it
would Echo here's that right there bro
he's getting over man what'd you say
what uh just give it a go let's give it
a go here we go
jockostore.com we got rash guards
t-shirts trucker hats beanies hoodies
um we got the shirt Locker subscription
echo's putting out a shirt every month
new design every month this is one of
the earlier shirt Locker ones this is
still one of my favorites though got the
element D and we got layers in in every
shirt this one's got the zero zero four
thirty four at the bottom uh no big deal
but great subscription new shirt layers
layers getting deep in the layers layers
it's like the first time Echo said that
and I was like are you kidding me and
now we say it now everyone says it it's
so true people talking about them layers
we gotta go back I don't know who said
that first I might have said that first
gotta watch the tape got to go back to
the tape man we'll check it out yeah if
you want to get some of those layers
chocolate store.com subscribe to the
podcast uh also subscribe to Jocko
underground.com we got that going on and
just in case all other forms of
communication go down we'll be there on
the Underground
uh Jocko underground.com we got a
YouTube channel subscribe to that
origin USA YouTube channel Jocko fuel
YouTube channel Echelon front YouTube
we've got some YouTube channels you want
some you want to get some watch some
videos watch some good ones
um psychological warfare on iTunes
flipsidecanvas.com Dakota Meyer just
making cool stuff for you to hang on
your wall got some books outlive the
science and art of longevity by Dr Peter
attia
just get that book it's a textbook for
you on how to be a better human so there
you go I've also written a bunch of
books you know what they are final spin
leadership strategy and tactics code
Warrior or the code devaluations the
protocols
discipline because freedom field
management I mentioned it today I had to
quote it today because I knew Peter T
was going to come at me
he was going to come at me
you gotta sleep
you gotta sleep it's good for you
take that mouth son take that mouth boy
uh way the warrior one two three four
and five
everywhere I go those parents are
thanking me because what their kids are
doing
so they're doing Jiu Jitsu they're doing
pull-ups they're doing all the stuff
that Peter T was talking about today he
talked about how you would change the
way children are raised his kids are
Warrior Kids by the way forgot to
mention that today
but his kids are absolute Warrior Kids
he posts the other day they're doing the
warrior kid workout they're in the game
bro
get the kids you know that book Mikey
and the dragons about face
extreme ownership the dichotomy
leadership it's all there Echelon front
we have leadership consultancy we solve
problems through leadership that's what
we do go to echelonfront.com for details
next big event
let's say we get the council which is
sold out we got we got a battlefield
August 8th through the 10th at Little
Bighorn I think there might be a couple
tickets left
so if you want to come and check that
out come and check out we got a women's
assembly run by Jamie Cochran our chief
operating officer what'd she say you
just quoted her
um can't deny performance yeah yeah
there you go well there you go you want
to learn about that activity go to the
women's assembly which I think it's
called Women's Summit oh so it's it's
the assembly now oh okay yeah so they
they had a you know a little name change
but the women's assembly uh it's a free
uh live event that we host through the
extreme ownership Academy got it and the
Summit is an actual live event via Sim
person yeah the assembly will be the the
the in-person event in Phoenix okay it's
September 14th and 16th Phoenix Arizona
so go check that out if you want we also
have online training extreme ownership
Academy
this is where you learn the Jiu Jitsu of
Life 100 that's where you learn the
Jujitsu of life and listen if you don't
understand Jiu Jitsu let me explain it
to you a person that weighs 150 pounds
can beat a person that weighs 250 pounds
that's what can happen with Jiu Jitsu if
you want to learn Jiu Jitsu of life so
you can out maneuver out think
overcome problems lead
go check out extreme ownership Academy
extreme ownership.com how how much of
how much of your
um career would you say was
relationships based like percentage-wise
99 99 right on 99 was relationship based
I
I I will have to think about this I
never as a matter of fact I just got
done saying this to a company I never
had to say hey like do what I told you
to do which is not relationship that's
authoritarian-based that's rank based
right never had to do that never had to
do that
very seldom and I can't think of any
examples where my boss told me like hey
shut up and do what I told you to do no
because I had a good relationship with
him they wanted to know my opinion they
wanted to take lead from me we were
influencing each other we were listening
to each other up down and across the
chain of command so you want to talk
about how to get through life in a
better way build good relationships so
we actually teach because there's this
is you can't if I asked you like right
now hey hey Carrie build me a a
40-foot gaffed rig Schooner boat would
you be able to do that negative no you
don't know how no there's skills you
would need yes sir it's the same thing
with building relationships there's
skills that you need there's things that
you can do to build strong relationships
and when you build a strong relationship
you build a strong team when you build a
strong team you get the results
so that's what we're doing
go to extreme ownership.com and learn
how to build relationships learn how to
make decisions learn how to get better
and learn how to lead that's what we're
doing also if you want to help service
members active and retired you want to
help their families you want to help
gold star families check out Mark Lee's
mom mommy she's got a charity
organization if you want to donate or
you want to get involved go to America's
Mighty Warriors dot org she is doing all
kinds of things to help
our veterans and also don't forget about
heroes and
horses.org that right there is Micah
Fink's organization we just got a report
in from the field did you get that
report from the field I did not okay I
probably should have related to you uh
currently Micah Fink he just
actually had a wrestling match with a
bear
and he was about to submit it
when out of nowhere flew a bald eagle
and the bear got scared and ran away so
we're still giving it to Micah
undefeated 100 100 undefeated in the
field he's out there getting after it no
but seriously Michael Fink doing awesome
stuff helping veterans First Responders
find themselves out of the Wilderness
it's an awesome program if you want to
connect with us on the interwebs Peter
attia is on Twitter on the gram on
YouTube and Facebook all of them at
Peter attia MD and for us Carrie Hilton
is at Carrie underscore Helton didn't
get that didn't get it huh still still
haven't gotten that one resolved didn't
get that Carrie Hill is there another
Carrie Hilton out there somebody has
that there is yeah and yep I hit him up
trying to try and say hey man oh because
he's not active negative yeah
did he get it before like yeah yeah he's
he's had it for a long time I I first
hit him up a couple years back and was
just like hey man like if uh you know
maybe we can work something out throw
you a hundo bro no interest zero
interest in responding yeah get some
computer out there I uh that's Carrie
Carrie's at underscore Helton and I'm at
Jocko willink just watch out for the
algorithm and just just please and uh
thanks to all the service men and women
out there who are on the front lines of
Defense around the world keeping us safe
also thanks to our police law
enforcement firefighters paramedics EMTs
dispatchers correctional officers border
patrol Secret Service all First
Responders thank you for keeping us safe
here at home and a special thank you
right now in honor of Dr Peter attia
thanks to all of you doctors nurses
that's in honor of Peter's wife Jill and
all the Health Care Professionals out
there who support us
in our darkest hours and to
anybody else out there and everybody
else out there
just remember
what Peter Tia said if he can change
so can you
so can you and that is so powerful it's
so true look if you've been on the wrong
path if you did some hits if you've been
doing some things you shouldn't have
been doing
if you're not as healthy or productive
as you should have been and maybe you
haven't been the best mother or the best
father or the best husband or best wife
maybe you've been hyper emotional or not
emotional enough and maybe you've been
lazy and gluttonous and just generally
freaking miserable
you don't have to be
you can't change overnight but you can
change you can do it
but in order to change who you are you
have to change what you do
how you live and that is something you
do have full control over and there's no
better time to start than now
put down that donut
pick up that kettlebell
and get after it and until next time
this is Carrie and Jocko
out